e e
welcome it is now 10 o'clock so we will
get started with the depart banking
department and please introduce yourself
good morning uh for the record my name
is Amelia galeri and I'm the bank
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire with me is Christina Martin
director of operations for the banking
Department thank you for the opportunity
to provide you with information about
the banking Department's uh fiscal year
2026 2027 budget
proposal um the banking department is a
consumer protection focused regulatory
agency that supervises a wide variety of
financial instit institions we
accomplish our mission by conducting
examinations of licensed and chartered
entities investigating consumer
complaints bringing enforcement actions
when necessary for violations of Law and
providing Financial education Outreach
to New Hampshire
citizens uh the banking department for
the purposes of the budget is structured
into two uh divisions or buckets I
sometimes use those words
interchangeably that is what I mean when
I say that the first one of the the
first division is the banking trust
division that oversees the activities of
16 State chartered Banks seven credit
unions and 45 non-depository trust
companies the other bucket is the
consumer credit Division and that
supervises the activities of over 7,000
uh lenses those are companies that are
provide mortgages mortgage mortgage
servicers mortgage brokers Mortgage
Bankers small loan lenders bunny
transmitters debt
adjusters uh just to name a sample of
the licenses under our
jurisdiction uh the banking department
is a self-funded agency we take no
General funds how that works is at the
start of every fiscal year we receive an
appropriation from the legislature or
the legislative budget and then over the
course of the fiscal year we collect
fees and fines and apply those towards
the
appropriation at the end of the fiscal
year any shortfall between the initial
appropriation and the fees and finds
collected is um brought into the
department through an assessment um on
our licensed and chartered entities if
required um and that is that fully
refunds the initial
appropriation so into our the meat of
our budget proposal um the banking
department is approximately the banking
Department's budget is approximately
86% salaries and benefits we're all
people we don't have a lot of things um
that need budgeting um we are 50 we have
53 positions all of those positions will
be filled on March
21st uh we have no unfunded positions no
vacant positions as of March
21st so when we prepare did you in
fiscal year 24 uh I mean occasionally
we'd get one because of attrition sure
but no I mean other than like somebody
say they moved to a different job we
immediately fill it thank you
yep um
when we developed our budget proposal we
looked out on the landscape of what we
have to deal with and these are these
are some of the things I'm going to list
are some of the things that we noticed
and took into account When developing
our budget um New Hampshire continues to
experience growth in the trust
industry um as of today we have 45 by
the end of the fiscal year we're
projected to have at least 46 trust
companies chartered by us those trust
companies have nearly $2 trillion doll
in assets under
Administration that makes new trust
companies charred in New Hampshire were
the third largest for that group out of
all the states so even though we're tiny
little New Hampshire we have a lot of
responsibility and a lot of assets under
our
supervision another thing that when you
look out at the landscape and see um
there's an in a notable increase in the
last several years and anticipated into
the future of fintech
supervision so one of the entities that
we license are money transmitters
traditionally you would think of those
like Western Union somebody who takes
money from one person gives it to
another howo however in the Modern Age
it's venmo it's PayPal we license Apple
pay we license Amazon um these are all
large companies that we have to send our
examiners into the field because oh by
the way most of these large companies
want our examiners in their office doing
the examination so we have to have
highly trained staff that can go out and
understand those Tech driven business
models and provide adequate protection
for New Hampshire consumers so in a case
of something like Apple pay are they
just in California and licensed in
California and you don't do anything or
or they have offices all over the place
or it doesn't matter where they have
offices so it doesn't matter where they
have offices their headquarters I
believe I don't want to say wrong I
don't specifically know if Apple pay is
in California but let's say they are in
a California I would assume they
reasonably are they would have
headquarters there we in most instances
would send exam staff there to license
them they're licens in all 50 states in
most instances um last year last
legislative cycle we did pass the money
transmitter model act which is a Act
passed by all 50 states to facilitate um
business-friendly licensure of companies
like that so all the states kind of work
together when we have so there's no
federal license of this no no all right
thank you keep going yep okay um so with
both the Trust Company the increase in
the trust companies and increasing
fintech industry regulation it requires
the department to recruit and retain
adequate experience in professional
staff who can travel into the field and
supervise those entities and really go
toe-to-toe with them and understand what
their business model is and what they're
doing and how make sure they're
following the laws and rules and
regulations additionally um last last
year in the legislative cycle we there
was a legislative change put into place
um at the request of the banking
Department working with industry um to
that effectively requires us to examine
auto dealers who take Finance
applications we always had the authority
to examine them but it was more
complaint-based and now um with the
supportive industry we're going to be
going in and examining all of them on a
regular basis and that resulted in um
300 additional exams that my staff has
to do over the course of two the next
two uh fiscal years um to put that in
perspective last fiscal year and fiscal
year 24 we did about 370 exams so it's
about a 50% increase in our exam um
requirement so that's kind of what the
landscape looks like for us at the
banking Department um so to get to the
nree of our actual proposal um we were
directed to Flat fund based on 20 25
numbers but we were permitted to
increase travel and training
lines first I'll talk about travel um
when we send examiners on site The
Entity that we're examining fully
reimbursed the department for those
costs before the pandemic we used to go
on site all the time for almost
everything the pandemic happened we went
on site for nothing um now as we're
coming out of the pandemic and trying to
continue on with our efficiencies that
we learned during the pandemic but also
do an adequate job of accomplishing our
mission um we've learned that it's okay
to do some off-site work but there are
certain parts of the exam that it makes
more site to go on site for more sense
to go on site for um there's Parts where
the company wants us to go on site the
most frequent requests I get and um if
you want to call it a complaint they UND
they're very understanding I don't know
if it rises the level of complaint but
companies want our examiners to go on
site to them and when I tell them that I
can't send them because of the budget
they're like why we pay for it and then
I have to explain the whole
appropriation and the reimbursement and
all of that and then they understand but
I that's the most common thing that I've
been having to deal with is telling
entities under our jurisdiction no I
cannot send examiners on site to your
company to conduct the
exam so that's travel and then training
obviously with all these large fintech
compan compies a huge um complex trust
industry um to complete um the mission
of the department and meet those growing
demands um I need to be able to train my
staff to go in and understand their
business models as I've talked about
additionally at the banking Department
much like I'm sure most state agencies
we're very lucky or at least I consider
myself very lucky at the banking
Department I have a lot of really
seasoned experienced staff I have one
staff member who's been at the banking
department for 30 years probably half of
the staff have been state employees and
most of them at the banking department
for 20 plus years and then there's
people like me I've been there for 13
years so we are very well experienced
but the flip side of that is a lot of
people could retire at any moment and so
I have to have the I have to be prepared
to send my new staff to training to get
them up to speed to replace that wealth
of knowledge that would leave when my if
a if a staff a highly experienced staff
member
retired so that's the travel and the
training um and then with regard to the
flat funding the rest of that that part
of it how we accomplished that um first
we sought internal efficiencies the last
time we redid our lease at the banking
Department we reduced our square footage
and we've gone paperless that's mostly
how we reduced our square footage
because we don't need the storage space
for all the paper um so that decreased
our rent a little bit made us be more
efficient because we don't we're
paperless
um the other another example of how we
sought internal efficiencies was to um
take administrative positions and
convert them into examiner positions so
for example the commissioner used to
have an executive assistant assigned to
her and I don't need an executive
assistant I can do my own scheduling um
so we took that position and converted
into an exam position so now that person
can go out in the field they can also
bill for their time as an examiner
that's part of how we collect capture
our our uh fees and fines Etc um we also
had a team of Licensing staff that only
did licensing and we took those
positions and converted them to
examiners and then we took the licensing
tasks and distributed them amongst the
full team of examiners and we gained a
lot of efficiencies by doing that and
that's how we were able to absorb the
300 extra exams over the course of two
years without any additional positions
so regarding that one would it help if
we Chang two years to three
years two years to three no we've got a
plan for it I feel pretty confident
about it I don't with the positions I
have I can do it because we really
talked about that in the last
legislative cycle and sus that all out
as part of that I see yep okay so I
thank you though um so those were kind
of some of the internal efficiencies
that we looked at and then oh sorry go
ah okay yeah um and then um we also
reviewed external costs if you will um
so we were paying for an entire position
a full-time position at the Department
of Justice however we were really only
using it for a few hours every fiscal
year so we worked with the Department of
Justice to unfund that I don't think
they actually unfunded the position but
our funding of it they they changed
their funding so we don't pay for it
anymore is that what I see on page 292
fiscal year
25 probably 49 yes 49 yep and you can
see we only paid maybe a th000 or 2,000
bucks in fiscal year 24 and but in 25 we
had to budget for the full position but
we probably won't spend all of that so
actually I know we won't spend all of
that okay so that's how that's like how
we gain the efficiency to um be able to
Flat Fund in The
20627 Proposal thank you yep
my page um and then another example of
looking at um external costs um we have
a project underway to move to modernize
our um Data Systems at the department
we're moving out of kind of database
driven systems and into a SharePoint
system um that SharePoint system is
being designed by us at the banking
Department um and so it and once it's
maintained and we've we our goal is to
shut down make readon our dat bases
effective April 1st um once that
hopefully that'll go as planned and once
that happens we will we we feel
confident that we'll be able to defund
one of our two doit positions that are
embedded with us the database
administrator position so by defunding
that position defunding the doj position
that enabled us to Flat fund everything
but the travel and
training and that's really how we did it
um I'm happy to go through more detail
dets about anything if you need have
questions um and thank you for hearing
me out thank you uh representative
Griffin thank you Mr
chair um I see the increase is roughly a
million dollars and I know I know that's
funded by Revenue you charge your users
and I'm wondering how much of that
increase is going to new users versus
previously existing uses so you mean
like lenses and chartered
entities oh sorry oh the fees basically
are going up by a million dollars right
no so our fees are remaining the same um
the increas is really due to our staff
the normal step increases and um that
sort of thing that's designated by the
contract so you're saying that basically
most of the increase in revenue is going
to New Uses right or increased
uses I I guess I'm not fully we don't
have more we are increasing lenses and I
provide a chart on the back of us that
shows our kind of steady increase
particularly in the trust companies but
there's not it's not a one for one um
situation like somehow our services let
me ask it this one yeah what what's the
increase going to be for a typical Bank
uh probably very little because the the
banks would pay the assessment at the
end and thank you yeah perhaps a tiny
bit for increased salary costs for our
people because we build their time yeah
other
questions not seeing too much here
um so so I think what you what you're
tell representative Griffin was sort of
what I was going to ask that
um in what the existing um banks are
paying you you're not changing fees
you're not changing uh so on how much is
fees and how much is uh
fines um I'd have to look and get back
to you it sort of varies so we also have
the two buckets recall so the chartered
entities are the trust companies credit
unions and Banks they get very little
fines almost no fines what they get what
they pay is examination costs and then
an assessment at the end of the year the
assessment is based on asset size the
trust companies pay I think 90% 85 90%
of the assessment because they're so big
um per the back of the chart um so
that's the bank's Credit Unions trust
companies are you saying an entity that
was two billion would have twice the fee
of one that's 1 billion it's not quite
that simple but yes give or take well
and it's so the fees that they pay for
certain things is the same but when
comes to the assessment that's when the
amount that they have so they pay 25,000
for an examination regardless of size or
not quite but give or take depending on
how long the exam takes it's by the hour
and then so much per asset yeah I see
yeah thank you and the asset if you if
you really want to geek out and go look
at it it's by Statute in RSA 383 11 I
want to say it is 11 11 um and it shows
the tit ation of how it's sort of um
it's it's by assets and it shows that
titration of what they pay for the
assessment
okay do you want me to talk about the
CCD fines because the CCD yeah tell me
about fines
because right now you're you're mix
you're mixing fines with fees right yeah
they all go into one rep like we don't
so we actually separate them out when we
transmit them to das there's buckets
with there's like one big but within
that we categorize them so I could
probably run you an exact report but I
would want to get it to you after just
to give you the exact numbers in the
sense that you're spending the
fs it's part of your budget yeah yeah
the revenue the revenue yes that's how
we so it's it's in my mind a little um
distasteful for agencies to raise money
for themselves in that sense right I
mean so like you could decide to find
somebody more in order to get more money
for yourself no well so we take
enforcement actions when there's
violations of law I'm an attorney
there's ethical concerns if I'm taking
actions just to raise money um I would
that would be an ethical violation for
me I would lose my bar license I don't
want to do that so is there how much
decision- making do you have in terms of
do you find somebody
,000 or $10,000 or something it's set by
Statute our fines are set by Statute um
each consumer because we're going to
talk mostly about CCD entities there's
each statute that governs CCD entities
outlines the legislature sets the feap
or the fine cap for me so it's generally
$2,500 per violation can be the maximum
but you can go look at our website all
the enforcement orders are public and
you can kind of get a sense of what we
normally find people um it depends on
whether it's a knowing violation a
negligent violation there's all sorts of
factors we take into account did they
self-identify it and try to fix it all
those things go into account when we do
an enforcement
action and this
$2,500 hasn't changed in a long time it
hasn't not since I've been at the
banking Department which is 13 years
okay and I started as an enforcement
attorney I see okay
um is it enough to
um encourage good behavior or is it I
believe it is I feel confident about it
I feel okay about it so you're not
recommending that we would increase it I
would not okay all right go ahead
anything
else representative wer we see
the estimated source of funds banking
9 divions
Christina it's based on how we collect
our Revenue so our assessment that we do
is 08 so anything that we collect for an
assessment is an ' 08 anything that we
collect for a fee or a fine is an
09 and that's broken out by 2046 which
is our Banking and Trust and 2043 which
is
CCD all right
anything else
no so would representative um eil like
to make a motion yes I'd like to make a
motion that we accept the banking
Department's uh budget proposal as
presented in hq1 I will second that
motion okay um any discussion no no okay
uh show
F all right thank you very much thank
you thank you
representative ail
um
e
e e
10:30 um we've been cautioned to make
sure when we speak our our red light is
on okay so we will um welcome the
commissioner of
energy and he starts on page
319 but maybe we'll we'll start on
339 just to see the bottom line to get
started how's that sound
GRE all right welcome commissioner
chin good morning uh thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Jared chakin I'm the
commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy and I'm joined this
morning by our chief of operations Lenny
radio um I can give some brief
background remarks or we can just jump
right in so um yeah we have a fair
amount of time if you have any kind of
small uh overview of what's going on
financially that might be good oh you
you you handed something
out all right so let's
uh yeah yeah let's start with this fuel
assistance because it's going you're
losing a significant amount of money
there losing on fuel yes I'll have Lenny
take that one first so if you're looking
at the um the fy2 24 actuals in
comparison to what we're budgeting now
it's because um in fy2 24 we had
remaining arpa funds and cares act funds
and everything else that was that's um
um supplemented that that program so
those have those have gone away um and
this is um just a result of what we what
we anticipate um having for those um
future
years so we're just being a little bit
less generous I guess is the that the
idea yes we're well we're we're we're uh
we're not being able to use those um
excess supplemental funds so um this is
on page 325 by the way what we're
talking about just to so everybody can
be on the same page but this this is a
federal program it's a federal program
uh it's it's they're
losing uh they had spent in fiscal year
37.7 uh million but they're expecting
more like 30 so it's about a sixth of
the
program
less if you see right in the middle of
the page
then okay but you're saying that wasn't
really the basics from the federal
government those
were no the 30 million is more in line
with what we see um on a typical fiscal
year C all right um good all right let's
keep going there weatherization
so weatherization um so weatherization
typically um that that Grant is around
$2 million per year um and we weatherize
about 140 homes on average right in
there um again this is a federal uh
program you have a a big list of waiting
people waiting for this weatherization
typically has a waiting list um New
Hampshire is a very old housing stock um
so there are many many homes that um
need weatherization Services um and so
it's with this grant we do the best we
can um but there typically is a waiting
list for this program unlike Li Heep
which we've not had a a waiting list in
years could you restructure the program
so that there was twice as many serve
for half as much each or something like
that well that so it's difficult because
the federal government um essentially uh
the the program requirements the
guidelines are all set out by uh by the
federal government there's a a
requirement to uh keep the price at a
certain cost per unit um so okay not a
lot of room for creativity there thank
you representative evil thank you um
this may apply to other programs as well
but how does the federal government
determine how much grant money you get
like for
this uh that's a great question I'm
trying to recall off the top of my head
for weatherization um I don't know I
have to get back to you okay thank
you and maybe when you when you bring up
a program like this you could point to
it in the in the house build one that
would
help representative lean
thank you Mr chairman so if I recall
reading through the budget uh there's
going to be a trans for Reggie funds
like $10 million could you tell us the
impact that will have um it's actually
not Reggie funds it's the renewable
energy fund yeah sure which is funded
through um alternative compliance
payments to the RPS um so uh we believe
that um you know that that transfer uh
even with that transfer we can continue
to fund the staff um and continue to um
implement the programs for uh this
fiscal year uh and of course new Revenue
will be in for the next fiscal year so
we believe we can continue to um uh
essentially carry out our statutory
obligations um with the funding that
will
remain so what kind of an impact will
that have obviously $10 million less is
going to have an impact it it will can
we be directed to a certain page to talk
about this let's
see it's page it's page 71 of House Bill
2 it's not a budgeted accounting unit oh
I see okay yeah we're going to get the
house built to next
week so maybe that would be a good time
to wait yeah was just there was there
was a line in here but I'll find it s
ianes yeah sorry I don't know if we want
to jump ahead to that but I mean I'm
interested in where in hb1 the RFS are
could you just tell us where it is it's
a continually appropriate non-lps
accounting unit so it's not in the um
bional budget it's a dedicated fund
which we report to the dedicated fund
committee and do you have do you have
information on how much is in the fund
now yes yes ma'am we do okay I mean is
maybe it's here maybe we're jumping
ahead but I'd be it's not in the budget
it's do you have something here no not
it's okay I'd be interested in the total
amount of funds okay we can get you that
information we can do that is it quite a
do you have any idea
roughly it depends on what your um like
what number you want do you want the
number that's currently sitting in the
fund or the number that um we've
budgeted for the the year so currently
sitting in the fund um it leaves about
uh 12 million that um we have left to
spend and then if you subtract this 10
million it would leave about 2 million
okay and under what circumstances do you
make decisions on to spend it I mean
have you been spending it down in the
way that it's supposed to be
or we have been and I will say that the
legislature has proposed um changes over
the last couple years there was a bill
Senate Bill 303 uh that did make changes
for instance it eliminated the uh the
residential solar rebate uh which was a
$1,000 rebate um and that was I believe
had bipartisan support um and we were
tasked with using those funds um or
creating a process for those funds
whereas they would promote um Solar
Development in a different way um so
we're currently in the process of uh
creating a proposal that will go out for
public comment very soon um where those
funds in particular uh will be uh
repurposed for uh Municipal I should say
political subdivisions um that are
pursuing
uh solar for their communities so we'll
have a a new proposal for that so even
though um so that's just an example of a
change that was made um to the program
uh
recently so so why don't let's let's
wait until next week when we talk about
House Bill 2 and I'll make copies of the
page on the dedicated fund so everybody
can see what's in it as of the last
report and and what's been change how
it's changed over the years how's that
that I mean thank you Mr chair I would
just say I'm just going to express uh
some concern that funding that was uh
generated in a very specific way um to
put into this dedicated fund to be used
in a very specific way is um under hb2
would be removed and put into the
general fund and I guess my other
observation would be that if you have
dedicated funds that can be re rated
what is the point of them and I also
wonder about the
constitutionality so just to um express
my concerns about the proposal in hb2
upfront so we can talk about it some
more when you come sure representative I
I would just also mention that it had in
the past um funds have been taken from
the RF for purposes not related to
energy uh for instance I believe in 2014
or
2015 um Governor Hassen I believe in her
budget or may have been a standalone
bill um
removed uh more than a million dollars
to assist the um Community Action Agency
Tri County um they were facing serious
Financial uh issues um and they were
given RF funds to essentially help them
get back on their feet so it has been
done in the past just just so everyone
knows
that thank you represent LE so is it
your plan not to discuss any of the
house bill two items dealing with the
Department of energy today yes since we
don't have hopefully Friday we'll have
the real thing okay there there's a
section and what we do have in house
bill to but I guess we'll wait until
Friday yeah because I think there's
plenty in house bille one that we can
talk about right I don't know got plenty
of time but we gotta let's wait till the
end okay if there's still time yeah okay
thank you all right let's go
ahead the state energy program sure so
the state energy program it's 100%
Federal uh funding um this essentially
funds our um policy work at at the
department um as I'm sure most of you
are aware we uh our department is tasked
with um creating the 10year state energy
strategy which we are up for a revision
this year um so projects such as that
are funded through um State energy
program funds uh also for several years
um we have entered into a memorandum of
agreement with the Department of
ministrative Services and we have
provided them with federal funds to um
uh conduct Energy Efficiency upgrades in
state buildings um for instance uh we
did a lighting project at a department
of safety facility uh those sorts of
projects um many states use this funding
almost entirely for staff um we've tried
um our best to um find opportunities for
the funding Beyond uh Staffing um so
that just an example on page
322 3 counting unit
um
3352 yes I see
yes uh I was going to ask on this page
on on page
323 what's contracts for program
services going away what's that so in
the past um that was done for what we um
for uh School Energy Efficiency um
projects um we have a different source
of funding uh a state energy um program
uh from the bipartison infrastructure
law and we're using those funds to fund
these so we reduce that amount and the
remaining amount is going to das like
the commissioner just stated on um
Energy Efficiency projects for the
state so if you'll see class 85 Federal
transfers to other agencies um that that
increased quite
substantially I
see okay so this is what you just said I
mean this is uh improving state
buildings yeah that's correct yeah and
there's also a big in increase in
indirect costs what's that
so we have a um federally approved
indirect cost rate um be because when we
became the department of energy it was
kind of delayed through our cognizant
agency is Department of um Health and
Human Services because that's where we
get most of our funding so there was a
delay in them approving it so we were at
the DI Minimus rate for previous year at
which is 10% and now we've um after
calculations were done and it was
approved the indirect cost rate is
25.1% so that that had to go up gotcha
okay and also oit is going up
significant that is based on we we um
previously only had one position
budgeted in here and now there's two and
we we uh do costs by person so um
increased do doit cost for the extra
person and why is the extra person
necessary it's um it it's not really a
an extra person it's just there was a
there was a funding shift we did a um
what we call a a kind of like a a
reshuffling of personnel within the
department which was given to us by um
when the department was created we had
that ability to go to the um uh governor
and councel and that was just a result
of the shift of um personnel and and
things that everybody was doing um for
more efficiencies in the department and
that's that um person was ended up being
funded by this um this uh Federal
program I see
all right let's move on Heating Oil and
Propane sure so uh the shop program it's
a data collection program that provides
fuel information um from the Energy
Information Administration at the US
Department of of energy it benefits
consumers by providing uh reliable and
accurate energy uh prices for New
Hampshire consumers um we update uh
during the winter time those prices are
updated um on a weekly basis basis uh on
our website so important consumer uh
information p and that that program is
so small that it's mixed in with um
other accounting units so that um that's
also in uh 3352 for 24 and 25 and it
just recently moved to a different
accounting unit for which will be for
well for part of the 25 but the rest
will be um be going to uh the
enforcement division in uh counting unit
okay okay next pipeline hazardous
another small one yes so um the
department of energy our enforcement
division um receives an annual Grant
from the US Department of Transportation
fimsa uh to oversee construction
operations and safety practices of
natural and propane gas systems within
the state so we have two Gas
Distribution utilities um Unitil and
Liberty and we have about 900
jurisdictional uh propane uh systems so
we have inspectors that go out and do uh
inspections on these systems um uh to
ensure uh compliance with uh safety uh
standards and regulations um also in
included in this would be what is
commonly known as Dig Safe um so when
there are Dig Safe violations uh our
inspectors go out um to um investigate
those situations um so we also conduct
training for Escavating companies and
utilities around Dig Safe um so that's
part of that program that's on page
327 starting at the bottom of the page
1888 is the accounting
unit
enforcement
okay so this is also gaining a
person so there was a um a movement
between this accounting unit and
3357 we have certain people that are are
budgeted certain percentages and in the
past if there was any funding from the
assessment they would be in a different
accounting unit but since the person is
budgeted 75% from this program I move
that person into this program instead to
make the budgeting a little bit
easier and what's inter agency
transfers that is a transfer because
people are budgeted 75 25 some some 10
and 90 um I have to transfer the
different funding sources from one
accounting unit to the other accounting
unit and that's the mechanism we use to
do
that and so you moved things around
between within within the department yes
so on page 328 right um at the top
there's a big number in 2025 only
for class 29 you're talking about right
yeah so um because I moved that person
that was funded SE with 75% of it out of
the other accounting unit where before I
had to transfer it into that accounting
unit back into this one now it's fun
that funding is is just sited here
seated
here
okay all
right why don't
we there seems to be so much motion here
between from from one section to another
let's let's go back to the bottom line
three page
339 so you're gaining two people
overall right from 100 to 102 how many
of those are vacant or
unfunded so in this budget there were 10
positions that were um budgeted as
vacant however nine of those have
already been filled so there's really
only one position in this budget that is
currently vacant um the two new
positions are just conversions so we
were already paying those um those were
uh temporary full-time positions that we
were paying out of class 59 and this was
just um to convert those to full-time
permanent position so there was which
was a zero sum of the for the
budget so are you saying from what you
actually had in
2024 you're
adding uh two temps became full-time and
nine new
people nine were vacant and now they're
I don't know if they were vacant the
whole year um they were at some point in
the year they were
vacant probably the only a few months we
we pretty we we pretty much fill
positions as soon as they become open at
least we post them and hope to fill them
gotta
okay all right
go ahead representative Le thanks
so U the site evaluation committee which
was generally funded the last time
you're going to have applicants pay that
fee the cost of that moving forward is
that the plan
or well I'll just say that there were
changes made to the SEC um there was
legislation that that passed last year
um so now for instance the administrator
is an employee of the Public Utilities
Commission um in terms of the funding I
think the goal has always been to have
it be um uh fees from from applicants
but um I I probably should defer to um
well I'll let Lenny well I was just
going to mention that it falls under the
uh Public Utilities Commission which is
will be next it's not really part of the
Department of energy except for being
administratively attached okay because I
saw there's one position there that's
eliminated you're saying that's going to
the Pu in the next budget yes that's
under the pu's bu so if you compared
page 336 and
338 if you put those together you'll see
the person right so in fiscal year 24 he
was on page
336 but for 25 26 and 27 he's on page
now for some reason for 25 that a very
much there's there's an extra $100,000
there um
under class 68 remuneration but maybe we
should
wait until we get to that
point and
consultants and Etc
so we should probably defer to the chair
of the Public Utilities Commission yeah
yeah yeah
okay all right so let me go
back to
um let's
see oh let's talk about enforcement page
so so there's enforcement and
enforcement
non-federal so what's going on with
those why why is the difference first
enforcement 1888 on page 328 or 327 and
328 those are the ones that do the um
the pipeline and hazardous material
which is partially funded by the federal
government and the other part is funded
by an assessment against gas pipeline
utilities only the uh those that are in
3357 the enforcement nonfederal they do
more of the electricity and other type
of um enforcement work for like electric
lines and Sewer sewer and water and and
other things that's a non-as accounting
unit and the gas accounting unit is the
1888 got you are any of these group two
employees
no no okay and
um do they create
fines they do the Dig Safe program
creates fines which all goes to the
general fund okay and it's not a lot
it's only like $60,000 a year I see
um
and is is really um 16 people necessary
between these
two well 16 would be the entire division
um so we have an electric inspector um
we have um administrative staff we have
an a director an assistant director um
so yes I would I would say this
team sure the audit team is also part of
enforcement so we have five Auditors who
audit the books and records of the
utilities um and their work is primarily
in the sort of regulatory functions of
the agency um but they're in the
enforcement uh and Safety Division so so
yes it's uh it's uh a what I would say
is a a small team with um a lot of
responsibility I see but they rarely
find problems it seems like um it that's
a good thing um we do we do a lot of
Education um especially around Dig Safe
um so uh you know our teams are
proactive and um we we don't want
problems yeah okay
right um all right so that was let me
see here
enforcement
okay
um next
page so on this one regulatory
support um both it it and plant and
property went away I assume that moved
somewhere else
yes um for the 2223 budget I had
separated these out to each individual
division but um for more efficiencies
within the department I took all the uh
regular um utility assessment related
charges and I put them all in our um
administrative and support um accounting
unit which is 1891 so anything in 28 and
27 that you see as a zero would have
moved to
1891 just makes it more efficient for
the uh the accountant and stuff to pay
to pay the bills every
month
so that's on page 331 and 332
right but I don't see oh I see okay I
see yeah yeah yeah
TW class 27 and 28
yeah all
right
okay 331
so in spite that going
away expenses under regulatory
support are up 15% or so from
20124 so from 2024 actuals to budgeted
um it's not not really going up it's we
spent less than was budgeted because you
if you saw the 2024
budget it would have been probably
similar to 2025 just we didn't spend as
much as we had
budgeted and then but it actually goes
down from 25 to 26 and
27 is that cuz some positions were
vacant or
something we had some internal movements
um of different positions um you can't
really see it here because it was uh
Zero Sum movements when we did our our
re-budget
but um
really the only the only difference is
we we decrease some cost in uh part-time
um we went from two positions to one pos
down to one position that was the
biggest decrease in that in that uh
division than you all right um
representative evil this is more of a
general question um are you concerned
since your since your uh budget is
largely federally funded could you talk
a little bit about um any concerns you
might have anything you've heard
anything you've already observed as far
as future Federal funding for your
work so for the programs that aren't
related or or or are not a part of the
iig the IRA um so those funding
opportunities that came up in the last
two or three years uh laws that P
Congress passed um you know I I we've
not seen anything uh any substantial
changes in the last month for instance
to Li Heap um or to weatherization um
other than complying with uh the
president's executive orders that might
pertain to the programs um we've not
seen any major changes um you know we
are uh I I would imagine with any change
in administration um there are some
communication delays on um programs
related to the IRA and some of those
newer Federal programs um but in terms
of what's in the budget um there have
been no major changes and we're
communicating with staff at H HHS US
Department of Health and Human Services
as it relates to Li Heap um and usdoe on
WAP so um I don't see any
issues so there were no lines of um
money coming from the federal folks that
were turned off and then turned on again
or anything like that just different
programs not for these programs right
for the newer Federal programs we have
seen that but but not for these we've
been able to do draw
Downs all right so since we have time
let's why don't we go to this uh house
build two issue that you wanted to talk
about
we will get there but we still have an
hour
so so
commissioner yeah so is this what yeah
okay okay there you go see how quick
this is so I happen to be the chair of
the joint committee on dedicated funds
thank you or have been and
um this is what we look at stuff that
looks like this and and we every five
years we we um review every dedicated
fund and I don't remember um this
particular one but uh when we reviewed
it but what you can see from this report
is um fund revenue and fund expenses
over time so why don't we start with the
question of why did Revenue jump in
2023 sure and uh for the record my name
is uh Chris Alon the Deputy Commissioner
of the Department of energy um so I to
take a sort of step back the renewable
energy fund is funded as part of the
state's renewable portfolio standard
which is a requirement that electric
suppliers be they default Service uh
providing Electric utilities competitive
suppliers Community aggregators what
have you uh that they purchase a certain
percentage of their supply uh from one
of five buckets or what we would call
classes of renewable Technologies um and
and so every state in New England has a
a renewable portfolio standard of some
kind or several uh but there's a common
market product called a renewable energy
certificate which is generated uh when
when uh a megawatt hour of electric
generation from a particular resource is
generated uh the those attributes are
built into this Market product uh that's
tracked regionally um and then used by
those suppliers to fulfill their
obligations under every State's
renewable portfolio standard so this is
a common currency this renewable energy
certificate or a wreck and so given the
competitive nature of that market and
the fact that it's designed to in part
incent New Generation uh there might be
that risk that we don't have enough
renewable uh certificates uh available
to meet uh the obligation and so if that
happens instead of just having a
ridiculous situation where the price
goes up infinitely they've built in a a
price cap mechanism called an
alternative compliance payment and so
those payment rates are set in statute
and index to inflation for each of the
classes and so when uh A supplier goes
out and they say okay the cost of these
Rex is higher than what the ACP would be
in New Hampshire they go out and they
purchase the alternative compliance
payment and that payment goes into the
renewable energy fund uh and and that
renewable energy fund is you know in
statute its uh purpose is in part to
incent uh you know either new renewable
electric or thermal generation uh so it
funds uh a number of things for the
department so uh the staff who deal with
the compliance with the renewable
portfolio standard uh that there's a
variety of tasks uh that are um you know
uh related to compliance and Analysis of
the RPS that our that our staff do uh
then there are the programs there are
the staff administering with the
programs and then recently the
legislature has given us new tasks um
that fall within the renewable energy
fund such as the office of offshore wind
industry development and energy
Innovation uh as well as a couple other
related to smaller pieces of legislation
in the last few years is any of this
compliance related to the PE done in the
Pu or or is it all in your department so
when a uh like a default service utility
has to recover the costs associated with
their compliance with renewable
portfolio standard that uh that recovery
happens through the Public Utilities
Commission and the department uh we
weighs in in those processes to say yep
these are reasonable costs to have
incurred they can be collected from
customers so we set the you know we
ensure that people are complying with
the law and the recovery of that cost
from a utility happens at the Public
Utilities Commission all right so the
utility pays you the ACP payment and
then collects it from the customer via
the Pu mechanism sure and and yeah and
you look into things like did they make
the right decision to do an alternative
compliance payment versus going out and
trying to go to a broker of Rex to maybe
save money there and so that's something
that comes up from time to time in your
department or in the Pu at the Public
Utilities Commission is where that would
happened but so the renewable energy
fund comes in so sorry that was a long
way of getting to it's there's this
market right and so the revenues that
come in are are variable there's a lot
of things that impact the generation
what might be out there for Rex whether
it's the weather because like a lot of
these are renewable technologies that
are season
dependent whether it's uh you know Hydro
solar wind uh you know there there are
fuel and supply chain constraints such
as like with with biomass resources um
and then there's just State policy
changes that can impact the market and
so uh as you can see in the dedicated
funds report thing that you gave me and
I just lost um we did see a jump in the
previous uh two compliance years uh in
that Revenue where it had been hovering
in the two two and a half million up to
eight8 and a half million so that was um
obviously a pretty pretty big jump and
uh that was happening at the same time
that we were undergoing some of these
pending legislative uh questions about
whether or not because uh prior to the
passage of Senate Bill 303 that the
commissioner referenced earlier there
had been more stringent statutory
requirements on the spending uh that uh
I think basically had been in wide
agreement from from us from stakeholders
from the legislature uh to not be um as
effective at doing its job particularly
with a residential solar rebate program
uh and and we also you know in part due
to uh things we've seen through uh the
commissioner mentioned the Das transfers
we've also pursued some programs with
municipalities where there's a real
value that we've seen and demand um from
towns to see if there are opportunities
for either Energy Efficiency or solar um
in a way that we think is beneficial not
not just because it incense renewable
energy but also because there are those
benefits to taxpayers and it makes a
more broad-based um benefit of renewable
uh you know initiatives uh then then you
might see if it was just sort of a say a
handout to a solar developer so uh we
were happy to see that go forward but
you know a consequence of that was that
we've been um developing these programs
uh that we're going to be be working
towards and uh you know I think kind of
as referenced earlier uh the
commissioner mentioned that we we don't
anticipate there to be major negative
impacts with this transfer and that's
that's true because as you see what's
happened isn't that we're planning to
decrease the spending the spending is
going to be kind of in line with where
it where it had been uh what would
change is that this $10 million rather
than going to increasing the spend for
for these uh programs that fall under
the RF would then be going to the
general fund and you know it's our view
that the legislature and the governor uh
can prioritize the spending
appropriately but you won't see uh a
decline in in the spending um it you
just won't see an increase so I would
say it looks like the spending is
increasing if you look at the
commitments column of 2024 there's a
much bigger number there sure and and
and that might uh just be a function of
uh you know we we did have you know in
that sort of that first year we see the
revenue coming in so we are going to
ramp up the spending a little bit that
commitments um obviously uh based on
when the dedicated funds report numbers
have to come in kind of lines up right
in that sweet spot of we've had the
revenue come in but we haven't yet got
the money out the door because you know
projects take time to happen and you go
through through the process um so those
commitments of of $5
million uh you know are are mostly due
to had been mostly due to existing uh
encumbered grants programs things like
that um and you know I I I know we can
get you the official numbers but we had
in
September um allocated another $6
million uh dollars uh you know budgeted
towards towards program spending um I
don't know if you have
that uh and then yeah so so what we're
seeing is a I
got yeah so uh one once you take away
that 20 million that 5 million that's
incumbered the additional 6 million we
had some Revenue coming in uh you know
takes us to approximately after this 10
million comes out uh and another 250,000
which Dees has uh as a footnote in their
section of hp1 uh which is gives a an
option for them to take $250,000 to help
I think offset some permitting fees uh
it it brings us to the neighborhood of
about uh 2 million uh remaining uh for
this this fiscal year and do you expect
this increased Revenue in the 8 million
range to continue or not uh it's hard to
say I I I know that just sort of the
initial what we saw for this this
upcoming fiscal year it's been down from
there I think it's probably more in the
line yeah for okay I was going to say 45
million so 4.5 uh million dollars in
Revenue um it it really is hard to
project but I don't I think these were
particularly High what we saw the the
previous two years all right
representative eel and then
representative
lman um well if it wasn't obvious from
what I said before um it strikes me as
very concerning that this money that was
uh raised through statute statute for
very very specific purpose is now just
being uh taken away from the renewable
energy fund and put into the general
fund I understand what you said about uh
Governor Hassen I don't know what the
purpose was for the million dollars and
what happened with triap triap may have
used it in a way that uh was beneficial
from a Energy Efficiency standpoint but
just because somebody did it before
doesn't justify it now um and um I I
know that we need Revenue in this budget
but you know we have a lot of dedicated
funds in this state
and it seems to me that this sets a
precedent number one and I was thinking
about it driving down this morning and
it's like we could run through a field
of flowers if the at if each dedicated
fund was a flower and just go merrily
plucking uh these flowers to help our
Revenue situation and honestly Nobody
Does it so I think there are real uh
policy reasons not to go pulling money
out of the dedicated fund yes it sounds
like you could continue to function but
it undermines the whole purpose of
having gathered this money in the first
place because you want it to be able to
make grants um so I have a problem from
it on a policy basis I also really
question the legality of taking money
that was uh gathered in this way or
accumulated in this way and putting it
into the general fund so
um that's my view well and Mr chairman
if I may note I think the commissioner
did understate um the the previous uh
you know uh transfer that we had talked
about in the 2013 House Bill 2 it was
$16.1 Million that was transferred from
this fund uh to the general fund and and
uh you know a million uh or so was was I
think dedicated to Tri count cap but
there were there was a a greater
transfer uh you know from the
Department's view it's it's up to the
the governor and the legislature to
determine the spending priorities and we
will do what she tell us to do thank you
did representative lean have more of a
question or I guess a followup to
representative eel's well stated
comments it shows on the uh renewable
energy fund sheet that we have the
commitments being by 5.3 million those
are commitments what about applications
that have been filed
uh that's a good question it varies by
program there are a number of uh
programs underneath uh the renewable
energy fund and we do have some
statutory requirements with how to break
down that funding including a
requirement that uh you know a
percentage of the funding be uh
allocated to commercial industrial
customers and a uh a percentage to
residential customers based on
essentially their their load share uh
you know in New Hampshire uh so
depending on the program we have some
rebate programs that are pretty well
subscribed and and could have a wait
list there have been others where we've
we've struggled to get uh enough
applicants uh and certainly quality
applicants to to justify each bucket uh
of of the programming so we can get you
information to whatever extent the
committee uh desires uh but I I can't
say that there's a a particular answer
for all of the programs out of the
renewable energy fund it really is
program dependent a followup Mr chairman
lks so I guess back to my question if we
remove the $10 million what kind of an
impact will that have on applications
that may be
pending uh so for what we have already
uh essentially allocated we said we were
going to spend that that $6 million that
I referen in September it would have no
impact on those programs uh it would
have no impact on our staffing um it
would say uh if if you weren't to do
this we we would have an extra $10
million that we would spend on these
programs at at you know at some time I I
guess Mr chairman I'm not I guess stting
my question accurately because I still
not hearing from you if applications are
out there and we remove the $10 million
will that have an impact on those
applications so to the extent that an
individual applicant feels like they
might not want to apply because they
think the money is not there that's
something that's in up for them what I'm
just telling you is that it will not
affect the the programming the the
budget that we've already put out there
um I I can't speak to what a particular
uh customer might might think I I'm
sorry if I'm not understanding your
question so in other words there are no
applications pending that the removal of
this $10 million will have an impact on
uh correct okay thanks let me ask about
this you you keep talking about you
approve 6 million in September what was
that for because that's obviously new
it's a much bigger number than anything
on this
page yep uh so that was just as as part
of the the normal course of uh spending
out of the renewable energy fund the
commissioner um will put out uh
essentially an order authorizing an
allocation of x a million dollars uh you
know to fund these programs open the a
program window take in applicants for
say a rebate program or open an RFP for
the competitive programs uh and so
that's that's just part of the statutory
responsibility of the fund is to is to
spend uh out of it and the commissioner
in September it was September 20th um
put out a memo confirming that
allocation um of $6
million so you can't say in particular
it went to more solar or more this or
something like that I I I'd be happy to
provide the memo uh you know after the
hearing but it it did have allocations
specifically to you know uh
$244,000 to do to our bulk fed pellet
central heating rebates program 100 uh
1.5 million to our LMI grant program and
so on uh dividing up that $6 million
within the variety of programs that fall
under the renewable energy fund right so
to to representative Lehman's question
you could have if you didn't if this 10
million didn't go away you could do this
again next year for example right then
and those programs could have that much
more stuff yeah I I would anticipate so
so the revenue is still going to come in
after July 1st and we'll likely have a
spending allocation that allocation
could be $10 million larger uh if this
was available it's up to the legislature
whether or not that $10 million is
better spent in these programs or with
in the general
fund representative cell thank you Mr
chair uh do you know if any of that
allocation went to Offshore wind uh
only to the um extent that our office of
offshore wind industry development and
energy Innovation staff worked on issues
related to Offshore wind there were no
specific programs or funding that were
sent to say an offshore wind developer
or anything like that um and and
obviously uh you've seen because it just
passed the house that there is a bill
that would look at reforming that office
and uh refocusing its Mission uh
renaming it to the office of energy
Innovation um you know there were
recently nuclear related activities
added to that office uh that have picked
up and and will uh likely continue to
pick up and we'll see maybe that'll
become more of the focus there are
obviously a lot of technologies that
fall within the idea of energy
Innovation representative evil um I
actually have here the New Hampshire
renewable energy fund annual report
dated November 1st
2024 and it looks like there were a
great number of wood pellet boiler
furnace uh um grants that were made and
and applications um so there's actually
quite a variety of things that um have
been done and again if you remove the
$10 million um you can't you don't have
the opportunity to make those grants so
um I again I think it's
not even though Governor Hassen did it I
don't know the circumstances yes she's a
Democrat blah blah blah I still don't
think it's really a great practice to go
pulling uh money that was generated for
specific purposes and dedicated funds to
go and do other things it just doesn't
seem
right so let me ask about this um
residential pellet boiler thing uh what
does that program do
uh good question and and I'm I'm the not
the perfect person to talk to you about
the specifics of all the program and
thank you representative eel for
highlighting we do have uh in additions
to our uh dedicated funds reporting we
on an annual basis send to the uh
jurisdictional uh energy Committees of
the house and the Senate our annual
report and there's a lot of good
information there uh there are two uh
residential uh well not two programs
related to the wood pellet uh you know
heating systems one for residential
customers one for uh commercial
industrial customers um the the
residential one has a cap I believe of
10,000 it's in here somewhere uh 10,000
persistent up to 40% of the cost of the
system uh and then uh I'm sorry I don't
have the specifics uh off the top of my
head for the commercial would it just be
first come first served among applicants
uh there is a there is a process that we
go through to to um allocate those
rebates ensuring that folks are eligible
I would have to get back to you if we
had enough sub description to get to the
weight list kind of exactly how we
waterfall that priorities I think it
might be you think it's fully funded
there's never a weight list or uh no I I
I'd have to get back to you on that
there there might be we certain be
interested yeah just because I heat with
pellets
so and it's my my system needs a new one
so
anyway um okay uh other questions about
this I think we understand what it's
doing what's going on here I think but
we haven't yet decided what to do okay
um let's go to the is it the Pu next is
that what we're going to
do page
336 good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm Dan goldner um
Public Utilities chairman I can give a
brief Preamble about the PC and SEC if
that would be helpful Mr chairman well I
don't know I do we all feel comfortable
we know what the Pu
does all right go ahead you can I'll
make it very
brief um so the Public Utilities
Commission has tasked with overseeing
safe adequate reliable service adjust
and reasonable rates for our state's
Electric Gas and Water
Utilities the Comm the commission's role
is as the
Arbiter of the customer and regulated
utility interests so we're we're
balancing that scale the commission
regulates over $2 billion in annual
revenue and over 8 billion in assets
with a small staff of 12 that's uh 15
including Commissioners where the
electric and gas Commodities can vary
greatly in Good Times providing
affordable energy for New Hampshire
citizens and businesses and in times of
high prices an area of considerable cost
and stress to the residents and
businesses in the state which the
commission Works to ameliorate through
its oversight
work uh the site evaluation committee uh
has responsibility for the sighting of
energy facilities the committee was
reformed by the legislature last year
from nine to five members moving
enforcement to the doe who you just
heard from and combining the SEC and
pu's the resources are fungible the SEC
um to the point of the representative
earlier has a single
employee so I can uh I can go over the
the budget if you like or yeah let's
talk about that so U just on page
339 you're going up by 1.1 million over
2024 to 2025 now some of that is the
extra 300,000 for the site evaluation
a committee right but
um what what's the rest of it for is it
is it just normal step increases and so
on I mean it seems pretty high for
that so you're looking at the actuals
versus what was budgeted yeah once again
like I'm I I might be some laps involv
just we didn't spend as much um compared
to what was budgeted for 24 mhm um
um and it could be there was uh well
there was quite a few of um vacancies
that were filled for the for the Pu
during that time frame so that could be
a big because it's you know is still a
fairly new um new agency with new
positions um so that that could be a big
portion f are any of these 17
vacant uh yes one is vacant okay but in
2024 more were yeah we had some ins and
some outs but there were more vacancies
that's correct
okay and because of the hiring frees
you're not going to fill this one that's
correct
okay all right and that's an
unclassified position it's not a
classified position that's vacant okay
what is all right under evaluation
committee what is class 68
remuneration that's basically for um
payments to board members for certain
things like travel and things like that
and and that is only that is coming over
from the site evaluation committee um
it's not wasn't part of the Pu before
when site evaluation committee was its
own
agency so you think that's not going to
be spent probably it was decreased from
60,000 to 5,000 right but I mean even
the 60,000 probably wasn't spent no it
wasn't spent uh we because of the
funding situation with that program we
were very cognizant of the money we
spend things on and we're very frugal in
there CU we don't want to come to the
fiscal committee to request General
funds thank you I'll also just add
briefly with the legislative change that
moved the SEC from 9 to five members
there's of course less uh less less need
for that funding moving forward gotta
okay
um other questions representative wer
then representative evil yeah it's been
a while since I kept up with the Pu is
it still three Commissioners that's
correct now at one point it was
recommended that one be an engineer one
be an accountant one being a lawyer is
that so what is the makeup now of the so
I'll answer that question two ways the
statute requires that one as a lawyer uh
one of the others has to be uh Finance
uh business accounting economics
engineering and uh the third is
unspecified currently on the commission
we have uh one lawyer as required I'm an
engineer in an MBA and the other
commissioner is an has a PHD in
economics thank
you representative V thank you Mr chair
I just wondered if you could explain the
uh application fee structure to us for
like the SEC and SEC yeah and when they
were last raised Etc May complicated the
table is in the is a statute is in
statute so it is required that the com
uh the SEC reviews it once a year and
can under the statute make changes we
have not in the last two or three years
that I can recall made any changes to
the
statute um I was um um in terms of
current SEC activity there's one item
before us it's the x178 transmission
line for
eversource uh we resolved a pipeline
issue last year but the AC AC it in the
SEC has been very light uh we have not
had a lot of activity lately and that
was what was helpful about the
legislation last year making resources
fungible if we get a northern pass to
we're going to need to be able to move
resources around to be able to handle a
heavy load and when it's a light load we
can um we can leverage the SEC
administrator into pu activities as
appropriate to to what extent for a
large project like that do application
fees help to offset the costs of the
work that you folks do I'm I'm I'm doing
this off the top of my head I don't know
if attorney spidel behind me knows the
answer but my recollection is that the
table varies from like 60,000 for a huge
project to a few thousand for smaller
projects and what we've seen while I've
been chair of the SEC since November of
21 is very very little coming in the way
of of fees because we just haven't had
that many
applications okay thank you yes I just
I'm Alexander theor advisor and I just
amplifi those comments by mentioning
that microphone you can use that one use
this one you can use that
M
um thank you state your name again um
Alexander spidel senior advisor at the
New Hampshire Public Utilities
Commission um I would just amplify that
by saying that when Northern pass came
in the the original application and all
its permutations from about 11 through
18 uh they were paying a lot of fees and
reimbursing um the SEC for a lot of
spending for the council for the SEC and
all those other invoices so when a large
project comes in they do reimburse the
SEC for its ongoing expenses and the the
figures can be very significant hundreds
of thousands of dollars
Consultants right uh yes and also
attorne attorneys and all the folks that
do the work thank you so I heard him say
the commissioner say um northern pass 2
is there such a thing is that well there
had been the Twin States project that
had been proposed recently and then the
developer withdrew it on their own so it
could come back uh there's always
discussions about uh Canadian Hydro
power coming down and new New England
Atomic power going up sort of in a swap
depending on market conditions so
there's still thoughts about that but
it's dependent on the investors the the
business people decide on their own the
SEC and the Pu do not control
that so this summer I visited um uh lran
2 in Rison Quebec which is 20 M North 20
hours north of Montreal and um it's one
of seven giant hydroelectric power
plants on this one giant River and um
what they told me was they want to sell
to us because an awful lot of people in
Montreal heat with
electricity so their heavy period is the
winter and our heavy period for
electricity is the summer because we
cool with electricity right so they
thought it would be that's the reason
they'd like to sell to us so yes it's
very interesting I don't want to waste
the committee's time but it may be um of
interest that in Canada uh in Montreal
there's curtailments being discussed in
the winter period there uh they have a
lot of heavy industry in Montreal that
was drawn in by the cheap electricity
from Ontario and elsewhere aluminum
smelters and steel mills and things of
that uh sort and in fact they're talking
about the fact they don't have adequate
capacity to serve their load so that's a
thought so they're interested in our
power as much as we are interested in
theirs so uh I we don't know if and when
any sort of proposal would be made but
it's always something that can come
about thank you other
questions no I don't see any all right
um did I have any general questions
here
um I guess we sort of asked right why
the 800,000
increase over 2024 some was laps some
was the site
evaluation and some was filling
vacancies yeah okay all right should we
go on to the consumer
Advocate who I see in the
room which is Page
334 so the previous
page good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Donald Cree I
am the consumer Advocate I just passed
my 9th anniversary on the job and our
task as a small and feisty office of uh
six people when we're fully staffed is
to represent the interests of
residential utility customers of this
state uh wherever those interests arise
most of the time they arise in front of
the Public Utilities Commission they
also Arise at ISO New England our
regional grid operator before the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
before neol which is the stakeholder
advisory body to ISO New England and
occasionally in proceedings in other
states and things like that um our uh
budget request as reflected in house
bill one is I think somewhat less
interesting than those that you've just
been discussing uh about the Pu and the
department of energy in that it's
basically um business as usual for us
the OCA is funded via utility assessment
not the general fund and uh we developed
a budget proposal consistent with the
instructions we got from the governor's
office and what you see in front of you
is the result of that are uh it costs
about $1.1 million a year to have the
OCA and uh I like to compare us to Maine
my counterpart in Maine the public
Advocate uh her job is to represent all
customers not just residential customers
and uh up in Maine they have a office
that has I think about three times our
budget and about twice our staff so they
do somewhat more than we do but they
also have a lot more resources than we
do
um I can certainly talk about what we're
up to if you're interested uh or I can
answer your questions happy to do
whatever would be help let me just start
with some Financial questions so you
have six people all V all full nonone
vacant is that right we do have one
vacancy at present yes but in the budget
right the budget is fully there's no
vacancies in the budget that that person
left
recently gotcha okay and
um but in 2024 there were more vacancies
is that
right no I'm curious about what's making
you think that well if I look on page
334 the first line um P permanent
classified Personnel went from 250,000
to 400,000 that's because we added a new
staff member to handle Regional and
federal work for us okay but the count
didn't go up so they had they had the
position authorized in the budget just
took a while for it to get filled okay
yeah so that there was a
vacancy I guess and this is an expensive
person basically probably relatively
speaking we we have an attorney who does
that work for us but their benefits what
what's weird is is their salary went up
in
2025 but the benefits didn't go up until
2026 I don't understand that yeah that
would be above my pay grade as
well do you know or yeah well it all
just depends on what you budgeted at and
what you you filled it with so you could
bu when you budget a vacant position you
budgeted as um you know Health Plus one
and you could have hired somebody that's
married and has a has a um has a family
plan okay um there could have been I
don't know if there were other vacancies
you know people being um throughout the
throughout the year not it wouldn't have
been the entire year um but really when
you're looking at what was budgeted and
what was spent you know spent is actual
so you may not realize what was in the
budget um and that goes for um Personnel
costs and and for benefits also okay so
in fiscal year 25 you budgeted for um
consultants and temps did you actually
use any or are you this year no that's
what for the uh tempor temporary
positions that's why we removed it from
the budget um so that that 56,000 that
was budgeted in um fy2 will not be spent
and for Consultants
um uh that we mainly budget out or we
mainly pay contracts out of the
litigation line 233 so that will also
not be spent gotcha
okay and that's why it was removed in 26
27 right so why is this sort of an a
separate entity and not part of the
Department of
energy um the department of Energy's job
is to advance the policy agenda of the
executive branch with respect to energy
and our job is to advance the interests
of residential utility customers so that
basically means trying to make sure that
rates are as low as possible and and
also that there is as much uh individual
freedom I guess you would say as
possible for uh customers and
um I've I've held the job for nine years
so I've worked under Democratic
Governors and Democratic legislatur and
Republican Governors and Republican
legislatur and everybody who uh has a
partis an affiliation has a particular
policy agenda that they pursue and I uh
I it's not my job to complain about any
of those things but it is my job to make
sure that those things are not unfairly
placed on the backs of residential
utility customers and so that's the
interest that I I assert and I do that
independently we uh unlike the Pu
Commissioners or the commissioner or
Deputy Commissioner of energy or really
any of the other Commissioners in the
executive branch I'm truly independent
I'm insulated from the kind of uh
political considerations that most
executive branch appointees feel because
we have an Advisory board that operates
as a kind of a buffer between me and the
governor and the
council and and what power do you have
to do things for the consumer that's an
excellent question and I I I hope this
doesn't come across as a glib answer but
the the the honest answer is none uh I
am the consumer advocate so all I can do
is martial my team and be as persuasive
as we can in uh calling for results that
are rate pay or favorable so both in the
legislature and at the Pu yes although I
would say primarily at the Pu uh
legislative work is uh a relatively
modest slice of what we do because from
my perspective policy choices made by
the legislature you folks are the
elected officials and I'm not so you
answer to your constituents in a way
that I don't and so I I accept it face
value as a given the policy choices you
make you know you were talking earlier
about the renewable portfolio standard
and Reggie and things like that I I tend
not to testify about bills that relate
to those things because I think those
are environmental policies that the
legislature gets to
make represent leean thank you Mr
chairman I guess kind of a followup just
where I think the chairman was going
have you have a fairly good success rate
your recommendations to the Pu to
because I think politically speaking I
don't think Democrats and Republicans
are that different on the issue of
seeing lower rates for our constituents
and we often hear that our rates are
some of the highest in the country so
have you had some success in promoting
uh constituents lower rates with the Pu
or are you just uh pounding at windmills
so to speak
uh most of the time we negotiate
agreements with other players in puc
proceedings and we do pretty well with
them so it's relatively unusual to fight
to the death in front of the Pu and have
the Pu say it does happen occasionally
but it's relatively unusual for the Pu
to say well I listen to the utility and
I listen to the Department of energy and
I listen to the consumer Advocate and
gosh the consumer Advocate is right so
we're going to adopt the consumer
Advocates position usually it usually
those things are hammered out in
negotiations and I think we have a
pretty decent success rate thanks thanks
Mr chairman representative Griffin thank
you Mr chair I'd like to get back to the
numbers for a minute the um benefit
package it looks like it's approaching
60% of
salaries and that seems quite a bit
higher than the other state agencies are
running and um I'm wondering what it's
made up of this driving
it it's basically if someone has a
family plan they get a family plan if
they don't they then they get a
different plan and there's really
nothing we don't negotiate or put in the
the benefit rates that's all done by
Department of administrative Services it
could be that OCA has a higher
percentage of married Personnel that
have families
other
questions yeah representative this is
perhaps sort of an obvious question but
if your office didn't exist who would
represent the interests of the rate
payers in New
Hampshire uh again without trying to
seem glib uh I think the answer is
nobody right that's the reason that
there are I I just counted this
yesterday over the weekend uh in light
of House Bill 610 which calls for the
abolition of our office there are 43
states that have some version of our
office uh at least as measured by
membership in our National Association
so there's something of a national cons
consensus that the regulatory process is
helped by the existence of a independent
rate payer Advocate ultimately what we
do I think is help the Pu make good
decisions right because the the Pu
exists to arbitrate between the interest
of utility shareholders and utility
customers well the shareholders are very
well represented
uh as I I think you can understand and
so if you put a little weight on the
other side of the scale then then the
process the public can have more
confidence that the process was
conducted in a fair and thorough Manner
and and then you have the department of
energy which is caved off of the Pu four
years ago and so it is doing some of the
same work that used to be done by the Pu
in a more neutral way our job is to
Advocate and that's what we
do who are the seven states that
don't uh off the top of my head uh there
are weird assortment of States Georgia
North Dakota New York for some reason uh
I think um
Idaho and I forgotten the other three
but it's it's it's a weird list because
it doesn't tell you anything like it's
not it's red States and blue States it's
States all over the country it's well
you did mention the state that has the
lowest electric rates in the
country uh meaning North Dakota
Idaho they have the most um
Hydro of any any state so it makes their
electricity very cheap I just came home
from a trip to Iceland and in Iceland
they are just using electricity there
like it's there's no tomorrow because
they they have tons of hydr capacity and
they have tons of geothermal capacity
because it's basically a big volcano on
top top of a glacier that's uh that's
dangerous but it's great for cheap
electricity other
questions okay we'll let you go thank
you all right so we're coming back at
for uh
doit that's a tough one would you have
any interest in just passing on this I
mean all they have with General funds is
$2,500 yeah but I I want to we have that
house bill we he's talking about so we
have to talk about that
why why the elimination of the agency
yeah but it didn't pass oh it didn't
pass well I don't know I don't know what
it did
whoops
e
e e
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the division one finance committee my
name is Dennis goule I'm the
commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology with me is um Ken
Dunn who's the Deputy Commissioner and
normally I'd have my Director of Finance
but she retired right in the middle of
the budget so
I don't know so you're Flying Blind
yeah well we are weaker than usual I
will say that um don't don't be
concerned that I have this lengthy
presentation I'm not taking you through
every word but some of this may be stuff
you'd want to look at after the fact um
on the first page just introductions and
some background the one thing I'd call
out is you know we are a centralized
organization in New Hampshire and and
from what I can tell in the research
that I've done we began that
centralization Pro uh process earlier
than any other state that I'm aware of
the the other Mo were probably one of
the two most centralized states that and
Louisiana of all places um are very
similar in how they're organized moving
on to page two um this is just a top
level look at our strateg current
strategic plan we actually I was just
talking to representative eel because
she's on the uh Information Technology
Council and she was part of that
development of this strategic plan along
with the rest of the council and we're
working on on the next iteration of that
and there'll be some changes coming but
one thing I would note is that there you
don't see if you go into the uh details
of our strategic plan you won't see
technology there it's about outcomes for
us and you know I use technology to
deliver those
outcomes um page three again goes over
um kind of some top level things that we
think about as related to the Strategic
plan and activities we do to support it
um the one thing you know a couple
things there that are um really driving
uh what we're doing lately obviously
adapting to Ai and what you know what
it's doing to us or what we would do
with it um one of the challenges that
states are are dealing with with
artificial intelligence is the privacy
of information and making sure that our
our vendors who are embedding AI in in
their products are doing so in a
responsible way from a privacy
perspective um the other is obviously
the transformation from traditional on
premise systems to Cloud systems which
is happening in the past 5 years of all
the procurements that agency agencies
have done or or doit has done for
Solutions all but one were uh the the
winning bidder was a Cloud solution and
that one uh that wasn't was the rim
system the revenue information system
and that vendor is also now deploying
all their new customers in the cloud
so moving on to page four um cyber
security um I'll suffice to say that I
feel like a hamster on a wheel as it
relates to cyber security we we keep
running uh the criminals and and and our
enemies keep adapting uh more quickly
than you know it seems each year they're
they're adapting more quickly and and
and developing new solutions to disrupt
or steel or both um so that's a you know
a big Focus for us so I have to ask a
question here do you do easy
pass uh that that's actually um the um
there's a a vendor that supports Easy
Pass under contract with DOT okay
because I think they've been hacked I
just got over lunch an email a text that
said um you owe money to Easy Pass click
here yeah and and their website is down
because I tried to log in to see my
account
so I'm worried that they they've been
hacked Yeah well yeah don't don't click
that link yeah
no yeah they came out yeah don't click
on of course I didn't click on I got the
very but the point is I know enough not
to but maybe not everybody does well and
and that's a big big challenge because
when something happens people want to
know how will how can you stop that and
the and the answer is you can't I mean
if somebody wants to creatively spam you
with you know to steal your um identity
and then use it for nefarious purposes
um you know there's nothing we can do to
stop that via well for emails it we're
better off because we have tools that
look at the emails and try to evaluate
so most of that gets filtered out but
for the texts that's not the
case and and cold calling as well but
that isn't in your department easy in
particular well it it's we assist uh
back when that contract was entered into
we were assisting with the the contract
but the implementation and support is is
all a third party gotcha all right thank
you and uh so uh moving on to page five
um key points here um we work you know
we have an IT lead for every agency um
in fact one it lead we have one it lead
who does 20 plus agencies all the small
agencies is one and then but the other
uh agencies mostly have their own it
lead that person and our finance folks
work with the agencies to develop their
class their doit budgets and um and the
results of that are what you see here
today um some trends that I just really
think are as valuable to go over and
then we'll jump into the numbers
is uh the the switch from traditional
license and maintenance model you know a
capital intensive model to the operating
mod operational intensive model has is
nearly completed but but and and so just
about every procurement that we do to
replace an old system it goes from the
capex model to the operating model
what's the big difference there well the
the uh the operating model or the
subscription model is the gift that
keeps on giving in the in the old in the
old days you would potentially have a
you know a one-time expense that might
have even been capitalized to buy the
licenses and then you'd have a say 15 or
177% of that annually to pay for
maintenance but once that Capital
initial investment was um you know Debt
Service there really wasn't any so if
you ran the if you Debt Service over
three or five years after that's done
you know the software was essentially
free except for the maintenance now um
with in the case of um subscriptions it
goes on forever and that was a that was
done by the software industry to uh to
flatten their revenue curve because it
was really bumpy but also you can see
it's it's a revenue enhancer for them
and a stability over the long term but
it costs us more
money um very significant price
increases particularly over the last
three or four years really we're seeing
steep increases way way larger than what
the the stated rate of inflation is um
and the the vendors have realized that
um you can't you can't not upgrade
anymore because of cyber security
concern concerns and particularly in a
state environment where we're regulated
by the multiple federal agencies and the
payment card industry um they shorten
their life cycles arbitrarily so you
have to buy new stuff and then we have
to buy the new stuff in order to stay in
compliance so it's a game and um so
that's that's happened and that drives
costs up as well and
then
uh can I ask you about are we on page
six here or Beyond y
I want to ask you about the very last
thing fiscal year 2024 expenditures
12.8 million plus 14.8 incumbrance carry
forward what does that mean well that's
what was encumbered during that fiscal
year but hadn't been spent
yet so you ordered stuff and that hadn't
shown up or a contract was entered into
or or something like that yeah okay so
that was and we put that there because
it all if you just put the um
expenditures it looks like we're over
budgeting by quite a bit but we're we're
kind of we're fairly close in on that
year to um actually encumbering what we
spending and encumbering what we had in
the budget so did that 14.8 million not
show up as an expense in fiscal year
2024 I mean it doesn't look like it from
my point no huh no it didn't it didn't
okay but you're not expecting to in
fiscal year 2025 to encumber
another 15 million or something well
that's that's the Run rate we'll end up
with you know carry forward incumbrances
every
year
oh okay
so in fact this this year it'll be
probably more because we had arpa funds
in in in there as well so but that we
wouldn't include that in reports to you
on the operating budget but it'll
probably be the largest ever carry
forward okay so on the same page it says
fiscal year 2025 137 million right yeah
but you're expecting to add to it
another 15 no we're expecting to show a
exp a a outflow an expense of less than
137 plus a carry forward encumbrance
which would then be our what our total U
commitment for that
year okay all right so you're expecting
to lapse some yeah from 137 yeah well it
could be you know I don't know what our
carry forward on expense will be this
time it's probably going to be um we
probably will lapse and I because of
what we've done on the labor side of
things which I'll explain um but we've
you know we kind of stopped filling most
positions back
in you know late September early October
uh We've we've hardly filled any
positions since
then um so so the labor Line's probably
going to be pretty low relative to
budget for what I'm trying to get at is
Apples to Apples comparison of fiscal
year 24 25 26
27 okay MH so should I start with fiscal
year 24
36.7
136.6 yes y okay and what's the
corresponding number for the next three
years um well again the um the
the a completed year will be a
combination of what we spent plus what
we can inumber and carry forward that
will be true for all of these years okay
how much we carry forward will depend on
how much got was uh encumbered at the
later stages of a fiscal year or a
larger contract that was going over over
a period of time so um we probably could
get you the what we think a carry
forward would be 425 but I I don't have
that with me today okay CU because I
really want to
know how much this budget is
increasing from year to year to year
right because basically the amount of
money we have to spend is what we had in
fiscal year
2024 okay and so we can't have a 15%
increase over that number that's our
problem okay well and and I I'll talk to
you about that in fact we're on page six
so if you like I can jump into these
numbers okay so there's there's
uh this is the heart and soul of the
presentation the first line direct
agency that's a bunch of different
accounting units that
are basically the agency direct piece of
the budget which is largely driven by
the agency themselves so what we did
once again this this period was work
with the governor's budget director um
James and agreed that agency overall
targets could include increases in doit
as long as they made their own their
overall budget targets so that's
why this is that particular line went up
a lot because the agencies decided to
invest in
it um and and um you know cut elsewhere
is what I'm assuming I you know I don't
have visibility into everybody's budget
I didn't look at it but right that's
what I'm assuming because they they were
able to make the the budget targets and
still have but what I'm telling you is
their targets were
inaccurate okay so by a large number MH
okay so if and the way this works is if
if an agency's under pressure and they
say that they'd like to cut their doit
budget we work with them to do that okay
in fact we've worked with if if you if
we showed you every single agency you'd
see that some had cut their doit budgets
and others had increased it and the net
of that became you know a you know a six
6.26 uh about 6.2 increase from the um
from year-over-year from the um previous
so so that again we we're happy to you
know if if B if agencies were under
pressure and they want to cut their doit
budgets in these in that area we're
happy to work with them to do that and
we have already um in fact we've done a
lot of work particularly you know Dr
we've done some work with we've done
some work with liquor on that banking so
there's there a number of agencies where
they said all right we we want to make
adjustments and we did that made some
fairly large ones at liquor that's
represented in in in this budget
already so that area is again it's a
collaborative effort we we Chang the
numbers but it's business priority
decisions inside the agencies now the
additional prioritized needs there
that's all
DHHS um and you know
the most agencies didn't give us any in
fact none of them gave us APNs except
for DHHS and I I have that that detailed
out later in the
presentation um so moving down to
Central IT services uh that that's the
stuff that everybody
runs um and and everybody's dependent on
we basically to get to this number we so
we there's a a $400,000 reduction from
25 authorized to uh 26 efficiency and
then another 119 going from 26 to 27
that we got by pulling anything that was
new and anything that we could do
without that's this that's a really skin
there's no no fluff or Headroom in that
at all in fact we're kind of worried
about that number because if anything
goes bump in the night which it almost
always does during a banum I don't have
any head room to adjust to it but but
that is um that's a pretty um aggressive
Target there that that we went after and
uh so so I'd say and that's one of our
challenges is all of the stuff almost
all the stuff in there is running and
it's inflating in how much it costs us
every year and more than on that more
than the rate of inflation
moving on to salaries and benefits when
we learned about the initial targets
from from Governor sonunu um I I sto I
asked I stopped approving
backfills um that was back in you know
sometime in October and um so we haven't
been filling for the most part a couple
strategic positions we filled in fact I
did get a waiver to backfill our
Director of Finance because we thought
that was kind of important and uh so so
that will be filled but for the most
part we haven't filled positions and we
did unfund all of the open positions at
that point in time in in the budget and
I'll go over that more detail later on
in the presentation but we unfunded a
bunch of positions
already um and and one of the you know
things about the structure that we have
if you look at it we we pull pulled to
you know 2 million in reduction there
and then it's up 1.2 in the next year
and that isn't because we added people
it's just structural step increases
things like that so uh so that is our
salaries and benefits going on to
Telecom there's a savings there um you
know about almost 700,000 each year year
over year um that's really came from
rate card we were able to rec reduce our
rate cards a bit and that resulted in
some savings there on the Telecom um
accounting
unit and that's that's page six um if if
you look at the top of page seven that
just details out the changes in in a
narrative form but I've kind of already
gone over that the top part of just
Telecom is the the standard phones and
cell phones both or uh no Telecom is
actually the phones and the wide area
network connections of which we have
okay um we have over 400 connections to
different Lo State locations and that
doesn't if you include all of the
municipalities and and police
departments they're connecting it's it's
it's almost a thousand total connections
but but we aren't paying for those those
are paid for by the the other entities
so but they use your services well
they're they're like for example the law
enforcement's coming in to spots to look
at to look up things and and the
municipalities are interfacing with with
um DMV for the work that gets done there
and they're using what's called a a VPN
virtual private Network so they actually
connect to our network but there's not a
Hardline wire connect it's it's a
virtual connection and the way those are
structured is they're structured so that
they can only get to the systems that
they need to get to they're not on the
entire State network but if a cyber
incident happens in a
municipality we disconnect that right
away anyway and that happens fairly
regularly it's a regular thing you know
whether it's a cyber incident in a you
know particularly if it's a ransomware
incident in a municipality we'll
disconnect that connection and then
primex goes in with their remediation
team if it's one of the primex entities
which is almost everybody and um when
they tell us it's safe we'll reconnect
it again so that's kind of how that
works that's your VPN vendor is it I V
what that's the vendor of the VPN oh no
primex is the risk pool manager for all
of the for most of the cities and towns
in New Hampshire oh I see yeah so they
so what happens in know if if a let's
say a town um gets ransomed and they're
a primex customer which almost all of
them are or a
school um primex sends an incident
response team in there we communicate
with that incident response team when
that team says all right we've got
everything safe now you can reconnect
then we'll reconnect I see thank
you the a lot of this is just analysis
here that you could look at and and and
maybe find interesting but the top the
bottom of page seven and the top of page
eight is just the total doit budget by
class so that's all of the accounting
units highlighted are the areas that had
changes that were worth
noticing and you can see where the the
large number of additional prioritized
needs and what buckets they fell into
and again most almost all of that's
HHS um and uh and then on the bottom of
page eight we'll we start with the
detailing out each of the areas so your
direct budget the bullets below it this
is a a repeat of that table that had
everything and the what's meaningful
here is just what kind of stuff is going
on inside that budget what type of
things are they funding with that moving
on to page
nine um we have um the additional
prioritized needs for um
HHS and this is detailed out and you'll
see later they requested that we remove
one of them so there's one that's off
the table but um the rest of them are is
what DHHS is requesting for for apn's in
their direct
Budget moving down to we we like this
table at the bottom of page nine it kind
of shows you where like the top
uh seven agencies represent you know 92%
of all of the doit budget and spend and
you know it h HHS is at the very top it
falls off very quickly from there um
safety being number two and and then you
can see where it goes from
there again page 10 is our centralized
services and again
we those are the things the bullets down
below that's exact same amounts that are
in the the summarized table earlier in
the presentation but this details what
we're actually supporting with those
dollars and then the Broken Out by class
on page 11 for the centralized and again
highlighting what's what's happening
there and you can see that um you know
there's some some Trends downward and
upward netting out to a a downward trend
and again that budget is running very
close to the edge there's no fluff there
at all so why is there no Personnel in
this uh the Personnel is all in a
Accounting in a single accounting unit
which is the next one next one I'm going
into page
12 so I talked to you about unfunded
positions
um we we right now we're carrying in
this budget as proposed we unfunded
unfunded a total of 39 full-time
positions that breaks down to 37
classified and two unclassified
positions and it also breaks down to 14
in the shared services and 23 direct
support so our roughly half of our our
staff are supporting an agency a
dedicated support to an agency so we
Bild their salaries and benefit
fully 100% to that agency the other half
are shared like Ken and myself we're
allocated out by
agency um according to a
formula and in the case of us it's
device count PC count the total number
of PCS in the state divided by the
expense then multiplied by the PC number
of PCS that that agency has ount they
get build
proportionally so it's not the um the
dollar thing that was on this other page
like um
56% HHS 165% safety oh that's total
expense yeah okay yeah but you're not
sort of allocating based on that no I I
mean that's just how it comes out based
on the allocation methods we have a
bunch of different allocation methods or
shared we try to we try to tailor the
allocation method to to what makes sense
so for us it would make sense device
count the number of devices drives a lot
of the activity so that kind of makes
sense for in a generic sense but say
it's a system we're allocating out we we
would try to allocate that out by the
usage of the system for each agency so
in the case of oplc for example they're
going to pay a lot more for the
licensing system than say um you know an
agency that's only has one license type
like like lottery for example so so that
that just it seems to make
sense okay thank you um so the UN UNF
funding of these positions is not in
consequential that that um you know they
were open positions and we were
operating with them open but you know
we're we're you know you always Trend to
a new Norm running you know 8 to 12%
vacancy rate so we'll we'll be down and
it based on how the budget comes out
once we know a little bit more you know
later on in the process we'll be
resetting
expectations to the agencies as it
relates to this reduction uh in
capability of doit so so all right
representative lean has a question thank
you Mr
chairman so looking at your numbers as
far as the uh
reducing these presently supported
funded
positions I would have thought there'd
be a greater decrease in your 26 and 27
requests and I don't see that but maybe
I'm missing something are
they well yeah um the so there were to
be fair there were already seven
unfunded in this budget so the net is
lower than that um but that's where it
came out for us when we calculated it so
and certainly I'm
gonna U raas this I hope Mr chairman in
the right way but I can remember when
commissioner Bailey was sitting in your
seat years ago and he often would say
well if we do this this year we should
see a decline in expense next year The
More We computerize Them less the cost
but I have never seen that
occur and it concerns me and I guess
following up what the chair said this um
there's a pretty significant increase
here and we're facing as you well know
huge Revenue projections negative re uh
Revenue
projections and on top of that I guess I
was also looking for something we
requested last term the general fund
dollars I know you're an agency that
just shows other funds but most of a lot
of those are general fund dollars if you
could put that together for us so sure
what in your budget are actually general
fund dollars that other agencies are
providing you know I'll I'll tell you
it'll be between 45 and
47% General funds on this and it varies
obviously a lot by agency refunding
sources for different agencies but
that's what it'll be in net total yeah
varies by agency and that's one of the
reasons I that drives agencies to either
cut or not cut you see the general fund
agencies may have been more aggressive
on asking for their direct budgets in
doit to be reduced I'll talk about the
sir the uh your question about
implementing systems and having that
drive cost down I mean that that was a
thing you know
when when back in the day when we were
taking manual systems and implementing
Technology Solutions to replace them
that was absolutely a thing but not
anymore well for the most part we're not
replacing manual systems anymore we're
replacing existing systems I I've yet to
see a new system come in that was less
expensive than the one it replaced and
that again and goes back to the cloud
inflation and the fact that um you know
there subscription based systems versus
the
traditional um licensed uh you know
Capital capitalized license purchase in
um maintenance system so that you know
in a in a situation where we were fully
automating an existing manual thing I
would expect there' be an opportunity
and again that's at the agency level to
start um uh start you know look at it
and say all right can I can I hire fewer
people now that I have this system um
what I'm also observing is in a lot of
cases that that if agencies are running
um systems and and the support of those
systems a lot of times they they're
having trouble keeping up already so if
a system marginally improved things um
that makes that puts them in better
stead for for uh completing their
requirements versus some you know
obvious opportunity for
savings so
um the reason for
upgrading if you're not getting anything
cheaper is because the old system can no
longer be maintained or just to get new
features that the old system doesn't
have so there's there's um that's
usually it I mean I'm a big fan of
running systems as particularly in this
context running them as long as it's
practical because it's a lot cheaper
than putting a new one in both you
because you have the putting a new
system in especially when you're
replacing an old one is extremely
expensive just the work of getting it in
and then if it's actually costing you
more to run it once it's in then you
haven't you know you haven't benefited
from the standpoint of dollars but what
you have benefited from is you have
something that's supportable now and and
that's what's driving it and and in most
cases we run our systems are really long
it'sit Broken Out by class again one of
the things I you kind of get a sense for
there is we're not you know the Lion
Share of the spend there is in CL you
know classified employees the people who
are doing the work were not super
topheavy you know you can see there's
not a ton of you know comparatively
there's not a ton of spend in the
unclassified space so pretty well
balanced in that
respect and uh page 15 is again Telecom
Broken Out by class line you can see the
the reductions there there's the one
thing I neglected to mention both on
page 14 and on page 15 is the additional
prioritized needs I think that was rent
that Das asked us to put in there right
so we I don't know what's driving that
or what where that number came from
other than they said put this put this
in as as an uh additional prioritized
need so we did
that's it for the current Governor's
budget if you look at page 16 you'll see
some changes that have already occurred
since then um one is police standards
and training decided to take an existing
position reclass it so they're not
spending actually planning on spending
more but the police standards and
training wants to add an IT lead they
feel like they have enough you they're
essentially using business folks to
support their you know all over the
place to support their it function so
they want to concentrate that into a
single person and we're working with
them on
that and uh so that's an increase we had
a a decrease at
Dr
um and then a u a
corresponding decrease in agriculture
which is an increase in the judicial
Council and that really is for a part
of agriculture's it lead would work for
the judicial Council you know so part of
his time would go there so they're
splitting which is there's precedent for
that like the fishing game and the
Veterans Home are sharing an IT lead
presently it's kind of different
businesses huh for the same person but
um and then uh fishing game did ask for
reduction in their class 27 which we'll
we'll do as part of the next you know
this phase hopefully we can get that in
and then the last thing was the the
additional prioritized need that HHS
asked to re you know to remove but they
still have all the other ones in there
so that's it's 6 million 6.2 million
minus this would be what you'd see for
their additional prioritized need
request and that kind of that that's it
other than the next couple pages are hb2
requests but I'll stop for budget stuff
before we jump into hb2
I think for 20 years we've been talking
about business
onetop do we have it yet actually uh
Taylor caswell's group's Implement
working on implementing the uh New
Hampshire business Gateway and it's and
it's looking really good that was that
was funded with arpa arpa money and um
we did we had a bunch of steps first
they did that analysis with McKenzie and
then we did a competitive procurement
and um a deoe won that procurement and
they're implementing
a similar solution to what Connecticut
did so we weren't starting from scratch
we have a really good project manager on
that and and I don't know exactly where
we are but I think we're either in
initial pilot phase with business users
or we're about to be live so that that's
um I can I'll you know what I'll I'll
get a status on that for you because I
know you ask you ask me about it every
time but it's really going to happen
this time and it's it could be as long
as 25 years that it's
been thank you that speed of government
on steroids I think yeah um yes no it
looks really good and and the project
manager we have is has a great deal of
expertise in uh in in Salesforce as well
as holding our our um vendor Partners
accountable so they're they're right now
they're running um under the we're going
to be able to implement more
functionality with the same amount of
money because of the discipline that's
been in that project so it's pretty
well-run project and I think the the
that Bea has shown too it's it's really
you know they have an understanding of
how to interact with the the businesses
stuff so I think that was a really good
place to be running that project out of
because their their leadership's helping
a
lot representative Lehman yeah I guess
before we venture over the house bill
tour hearing representative Wilder's
question got me thinking back to the
audit that we heard in fiscal while ago
month or so ago uh one of the requests
was
legislation uh was required and
representative wer said he'd be
available to take that has that been
accomplished yeah we'll we were talking
about it today we'll get that we'll get
some language over to you yeah I think
there's one or two items that that would
take care of and just further if I could
Mr chairman U it was suggested a
corrective action plan to try to take
care of some of these U oversights
perhaps on your department is that have
you got a group together or you
developed a plan to address some of the
concerns yeah actually we have a a plan
for each item um and that we're uh we're
targeting knocking those all off we
we're slowed down a little with our our
it's most of them are in the finance
department so we've got we have hired a
new Finance director we're going to get
rolling on those but uh yes we do have a
plan for each item thanks thanks Mr
chairman so I want to ask about a age in
um so so I I wrote that I looked through
House Bill one and looked at the
individual agencies and how much more
they were spending on it and the worst
page is Page
44 which has Lottery and
Dr okay um so Lottery is going in 2024
was 100,000 it's going to
750,000 so what's what's going on with
that
one first of all I don't believe that I
don't know how they H how Lottery can be
run with only
100,000 yeah worth a ID right they're
planning on the
slots yeah yeah I I suspect they shifted
some existing funds into class existing
expenses into class 27 because we're the
only increase that that you know so why
is Lottery only have forly only have
100,000 in there because most of the
systems are funded out not in the doit
budget but that that looks like they
shifted some existing funded the only
increase they had was they're
implementing a customer relationship
management system in Salesforce but that
wouldn't to me that wouldn't account for
750,000 but we we'll get I'm not going
to try to pretend I know so I'll I'll
get you an answer they're in a different
division so I'd like to okay find out
yeah but Dr them Dr is just as bad well
not quite just as bad well it's going
from 800 and something to 3.8 million so
it's an extra three million it's not as
big a a multiplier but
it's it's a bigger
number yeah yeah so it's in the
Consulting line
item yeah is it so this is 25 and then
they cutting they're cutting it
actually yeah so you're you're talking
about class 46 the Consultants line item
I guess so yeah which was
55724 and 2.2 million this year so
that's for their rims
Consultants they actually reduced it
they reduced it for FY 26 and
27 they reduced it from 2.2 million to
the
1.88 right and then there's another one
and a half million of new software yeah
and that's the that's their Rim system
but is that the new did they move that
into our budget because I don't think it
was there before yeah it it's the
um I would I would uh have to come back
to you with more details but I think um
Lind uh commissioner Stepp's really in
possession of the details of of that and
and our it lead Karen so we can get you
that information together make sure it's
all explained to you but again that's a
great example of a system that you know
we we brought it in because the Sy the
old system wasn't performing well I mean
it is doing what it's supposed to do
which is generating more you know for
for the effort placed it's generating
more Revenue but um at a cost both in
terms of the software licensing and as
and in terms of the you know the monies
that it requires to support it now one
of the things that um dra has done that
other states haven't done is they did
proportionately lower Consultants on
that than other states have done most
States when they put in a um system from
fast that's the name of the company fast
systems they staff it all with fast
Consultants at a you know huge cost and
and what commissioner Stepp's done is
balance that having some fast
Consultants but also having the doit and
the Dr team support a lot of the
functions that a fast consultant might
be supporting in other
states but we'll get we'll we'll follow
up with details on both the Dr and the
lottery okay I
mean there's several others that have
big increases on this list uh military
Das um
oplc
Insurance uh
pu etc etc so
um we'll we'll get we'll we'll go
through it we'll find them all and we'll
get you we'll get you a narrative for
each one all right thank you um now you
wanted to you had a few minutes you
wanted to talk about how two
yeah so House Bill
two
um all right so the um a while back we
established a Chief privacy officer and
what we discovered afterwards that we
didn't have the you know we did did only
part of the work there's two steps one
is getting the position established the
second is actually getting it in into
legislation so that it it that um so
that this would cover that although we
don't have the money in the budget to
fund it but I mean I think it would we
should get this done so if some at some
point we can afford a Chief privacy
officer we could we could fill that
position so no one is currently
hired no
okay no we we have it's one of the
positions we
unfunded okay yeah and and during this
bium so far we for a while we were
running a pretty low vacancy rate so um
we
actually didn't have the money to hire
it even if we it was fully
authorized
um
the uh the second one is it's been in
place for I think this will be the third
bium if this should it pass it allows us
to strategically adjust who we hire so
if somebody so the way I un I'll give
you a great example the way I unfunded
positions wasn't This brilliant
strategic plan on my part it was what
positions were open that might not have
been the smartest way to do it so this
allows us during the next bium should it
pass to adjust over time to make sure
we're putting the money at the highest
priority so it's a really I think this
is a really smart thing to do and it's
not like we're going to spend more money
we we're just going to do a better job
with the money we have so that's the net
of that one and then the last one this
is an audit finding fix that we talked
about at the fiscal the other day so
that's the one I mentioned so that that
corrects one of the findings already and
I'll we'll get you language uh chairman
wer for the for the others that we had
in
mind okay and that's concludes our
presentation so there's these are all
things you want in house bill to but no
no they're they're in there oh these are
all in I see yeah
we okay we had sent this in and they
they put well as far as I know they're
in there I hasn't been published yet I
don't think but um all right
representative
Griffin I was looking at class 42
042 uh additional fringe benefits I
wondered what that
was uh it's on
page seven
14 uh 14 near the end well it's that's
included in every that's included in any
accounting unit that has
personnel and it's part of the total
benefits package I'm I'm not sure
exactly what it is but every every um
accounting unit that has in the state
that has staff has
that it's not something we just get a
formula from d and that drives what we
put in there Melissa do you know one
explanation I heard once was the um
people that retire hred from your
agency it's not enough in the retirement
system to cover them so they throw it in
the agency they retired from that was
one explanation I heard some time ago
yeah I mean I it's it's a good question
so that's one of the ones we don't think
about very much because we just get
formulas from dask and then we put in
what they tell us to put in but can can
we get a followup on that can Melissa
thank you so additional FR uh fringe
benefits representative W wer you're
close on that so it is for
postretirement it's a way for the
general fund to claw back these
retirement funds from other funded
agencies so it is a Formula that Das
gives them and anybody who is not a
general funded agency but has retirement
benefits as your employees do this is
the that this is the line where it
covers
that yes it
is oh because your AG
yeah so what you're saying is this is
payments that come out of das's general
fund budget but might go to somebody who
was lottery funded or something else
right and and this is a way of having
that fund pay back the general f yeah
like an in agency transfer way for it to
CL back into the general fund got thank
you you're welcome right other questions
representative you so I know you're
going to follow up and get get the
information and we don't have to do a
guessing game but when we were talking
about the Consultants line bumping up I
remembered when uh Lindsay was here we
were talking about rims and it had been
covered through the capital budget and
so what it I'm I'm looking at her
handout here it says seven-year contract
expires on December 31st
2025 Dr expects to enter into three
threeyear extensions at the conclusion
of the initial contract then it says
ongoing hardware and software support
and maintenance will need to transition
into dr's operating budget so is that
yeah that that that explain yeah that
makes sense to me because um because
everything she had people hired and
whatever everything had been through the
operating budget so now she's going to
transfer Ty I mean the capital budget
it's okay you know once you're once
you're done implementing
um then you then it's appropriate that
it transition off of a one-time funding
source into a ongoing operating expense
yeah so because I remember her talking
and the other thing that's happening at
at fast systems on the rim system is
that they're they're evolving the the
software as well so they have some
expense I think they'll have expenses
and do have expenses related to keeping
up with the latest versions and things
like that and and there'll be uh some
some work and expense in the future to
you know when at some point when fast
systems decides to no longer support a
on premise version of their software
they'll be you know I don't I don't know
if that's in this bium or in a future
bium but they'll there'll be a time when
that system has to transition into their
Cloud environment versus the right now
that system is sitting in our data
center at 27
Hazen are there other agencies whose uh
software is on the ropes that we're
going to have to be um absolutely yeah
yeah absolutely and that's one of the
interesting things that comes up at the
executive counsil right they'd like us
to rebid everything right they don't
like Soul Source but Soul sourcing these
a lot of these contracts is the absolute
least expensive way to do things because
you you repr procure and then you have
that giant implementation Cost Plus a
new system that's probably going to be
more expensive than the old one because
nothing's going down so we'll be we'll
be facing that challenge you know
talking about system Soul Source
contracts we're bringing before the
executive counsil as as that
occurs but they um but you know what one
of the things where we work on each bium
with each agency is there um their
Agency information technology plan aitp
which is required by Statute that the
agency do we work with them very closely
to get it done and and and what we like
to see in there is what are there plans
for their application portfolio
especially for their critical
applications and and um you know what
are the drivers and what what has to get
done and in what time frame particularly
if they have a end of life product so if
if a if you're in a regulated industry
you know data is regulated by some
federal agency or the payment card
industry and the software vendor
announces end of life then you have
eventually you're backed into a corner
you have to go to their latest version
or you have to repr procure and
sometimes going to their latest version
is just as difficult as getting a new
one so we each time that has to be
re-evaluated for each application
there's no one right answer for
that one other question um I don't know
if you can answer this but just um
looking ahead a little bit in hb2
there's um some big changes going going
on as far as
permitting um with Dees and fishing game
and dncr is that going to involve
soft a lot of it type expense or or
maybe you're not ready to talk about I I
I guess that it it will involve some
work um but I I haven't seen the
language so I I don't okay on my uh
paper here fish and games it costs are
going up
150% so
is that without hb2 though or I wonder
anyway we may see you again in that
conversation yeah so it's going to be
here yeah well happy to come down and
chat okay we have two minutes of recess
mhm
e
e e
started
here um because we we only have half an
hour so let's get
started and we're going to start on page
152 all
right so
152 it's the last page of the treasury
and so we will Rec
recognize uh Treasurer m
hello and um you know we're we're
particularly interested in in your
Agency for the same reason that uh
Willie Sutton was interested in Banks
right I
mean that's where the money is
so um I see you have a whole
presentation here but I I have a long
list of questions for half an hour so
I'm wondering if you mind if I just kind
of jump
into because I think um we'll probably
get to a lot of the presentation as we
go um so number one you're you're adding
a position yes um are there any vacant
positions or unfunded
positions good afternoon um chairman and
members of the committee for the record
State Treasurer Monica mapelli no uh
right now we're very fortunate we don't
have vacancies and um that is a request
um for an entry level accounting
position
and the reason
um understanding the current situation
the reason we uh requested that position
is because of the anticipated work that
we see um um that will come with the um
upgrade of the financial
system uh we see um we see some changes
happening so we're we're actually
transfering some positions from one
division to another but this particular
position will assist with the
approximately 40 um custodial in trust
accounts that we going to uh begin
accounting properly and accounting
system right now those accounts are in
spreadsheets as we I think I mentioned
in in in other meetings um I have
attended um it is a Time the state
accounts for those um um those that
activity properly and so we plan to do
that and so that will just um create
additional work for that business office
so um I'm um respectfully requesting
that position understanding that that
could be obviously um reconsidered but
that's that's the reason for the request
and Which accounting unit is that in
that is going in
okay great um now on this page you can
see a problem that also appears on page
141 if you look at other funds and
fiscally year
2025 so the meals and rooms tax
distribution to uh
towns disappeared from that
line that is correct so um the meals um
the meals and room stock distribution
was not budgeted during the last bium um
we had included in the agency budget and
I think the house um included it as well
but the Senate removed it so so it was
no longer part of the budget however
it's the activity stayed because we had
to pay um the distribution to the
municipality so you don't see it in the
budget but if you see the accounting
system you will see that activity right
now so that was 136
million um the agency budget for it was
136 million 136 million in FIS year 25
gotcha so it is increasing about 2% and
26 in about 4% and
right and obviously we will substitute
our own meals and rooms tax estimates
for these numbers right so um okay so
and it was just taken out just to make
the budget look smaller is that is that
what we think yeah okay all right yeah
we don't know okay good well
that oh sure sure I understand okay
maybe they'll do it again right who
knows okay um now back to page
152 um it looks like um some of
these um numbers are kind of creeping up
152 yeah this is just the grand totals
here right
um
so expens
let me see
here yeah it go ahead what I was going
to say is um you may see some again um
so I mentioned just briefly um we made
some transfers so there were we transfer
three positions from different divisions
or accounting units to um the um
treasury operations accounting unit and
that's again because of the anticipated
changes that were we seeing coming with
the conversion of the accounting system
uh with that what we're trying to do
obviously we're trying to um take
advantage of all the of new
functionality that is coming with the
system right now there are two positions
um there are in the office of investment
and Deb management that um they what
they do is approve cash receipts all of
them so um Our intention is to combine
that with the reconciliation unit so
they can only do reconciliation and not
do it twice so right now we're trying to
simplify that so we're um again it's
unclear
how when we're going to see some of
those efficiencies so right now we're
just transferring um employees from one
place to another and and you and that
may be the reason why you're seeing some
increases in some accounting units
because in total the general fund did
not increase the only area that was not
so we met the governor's budget of um um
decreases of 4% with the exception of
that service just because we did not
include that service in that in that um
in that request but everything else was
a reduction of the general fund okay
let's talk about um B the big stuff so
like general
fund roughly 80 million a year uh 24 25
26 down to 75 and then
27 up to
85 so is that simply shifting things
from year to year or did something did
the governor somehow take away something
in the general funds in 26 so Deb
service will be The Driver of any
increases um the Deb service okay Debt
Service funded with General funds which
is on
page uh page
143 so Debt
Service um
includes our existing Debt Service and
also we are assuming that we will bond
approximately 60 million each year with
the exception of now fisc year 26 so in
fisc year 26 we anticipate we're going
to bond an additional 40 million for the
prison again that was approved last
during the last legislative session so
normally our assumptions are about 60
million each year but for that we're
going to bump it to 100
um so um that's actually how we
initially prepare those those
assumptions those calculations uh when I
spoke to the governor's office they
mentioned an amount of about 130 million
for the capital budget uh but now it it
looks like it's the capital budget um
funded with General funds is 140 million
so one of the things that I I I have for
you today is a recalculation of that
debt service and fiscal year 27
increases above by approximately 550,000
um so I
have that uh revision if you want to
consider again if that that is if that
is if the house and the Senate um if the
budget the recommended budget is
approved the way it is right
now um so why
is why is the death service for fisol
year 26 so different from
27 because when we Bond so so for
example right now I just we just defer
the the 40 million to next year so we're
not right now we're ready to to in a
couple in a few weeks we're going to
issue bonds um those are fiscal year 25
bonds so you won't see any activity any
Debt Service until the foll fiscal year
so that's that's what we're by deferring
the 40 million to FIS year 27
essentially the increase in thatb
service is going to be reflected in fisc
year
27 but the difference is nothing like
like 40 million it's only 9 million is
the debt service is not the 40 million
is it's um oh
I the 40 million is what was approved so
we're going to start bonding that and
then that service will start increasing
based on that over the next 20
years okay I thought we were doing 40
million a year not 40 million once for
buying oh I don't believe that has
passed so that's um I see that's not um
so this is related to what's in the
governor's version of the capital budget
it's actually what was passed during the
last legislative session so that was uh
approved in um 2024 so that's already
approved and passed that's what we're
including in this
budget now was now what has not been
considered haven't been issued yet oh
they haven't borrowed the 40 million we
something from trying to remember who
told me this but they've got like 50
million set aside and they still haven't
got all the contracts approved for the
planning and the plan and all this stuff
and that 50 million May cover it so we
may not know exactly how many how much
expensive this prison will be with an
initial Assumption of 400 million but
okay they've accumulated 50 million they
still got a lot of work to do they've
got to get approval for the site they're
going to do sces and so on of it and and
all that sort of stuff for the priest
stuff and then go out and get an an
architect to design within that
footprint or whatever they end up with
so this could be a lengthy thing and
maybe we might not even need to borrow
the 40 million in the second year if
it's going to take them 17 18 20 months
to even get ready to to have brown
breaking all right so let's ask the
question the other way if we did not
borrow 40 million what would change here
it would be the amount in FIS year
27 it will
be um it will be a lot less it will be
close to what's in the 26
budget okay we're saving the debt the
debt payment not the 40 million correct
bonded but the amount you'd have to pay
every year for the bond correct the
authorization has been that has been
already approved so if they're not ready
to bond anything then we'll just defer
that payment until they're ready to
spend the money we will only Bond when
they spend the money not before I see so
this is not about this year's uh House
Bill 25 right this was already in a
previous it it's a combination of of
It's a combination so it's existing that
service uh funds have been approved not
and and not issued yet and then what we
anticipate is going to be part of um the
capital budget so if the capital budget
approves um again right now it's 140
million so I imagine a portion of that
will be spent and budgeted in 26 and 27
okay but borrowing 40 why does that
cause a one-ear increase in payments of
nine I mean isn't that way high no well
that that's the calculation and we
assume they're going to spend the entire
40 million I mean I don't really know if
if they will spend a portion or not but
typically um for something like that and
we we don't know the details we just
include the I guess worst case scenario
but you pay it off over what period of
time the 40 minut it will be uh a period
of 20 years amortization of 20 years so
you're not going to pay 9 million a year
for 20 years to to borrow 40 now that
doesn't make sense sometimes The Upfront
payments are higher than later on
they
are it just doesn't make sense to me
so well can you make like an
amortization schedule or something I can
I don't have it here right now but I can
certainly show you how that looks like
yes definitely okay um and and we're
going to see Corrections a week from
today is that right
Melissa Friday okay can we have a page
for that day that shows what's going on
with the new Men's prison both
operating expenses and capital budget
expenses okay yeah thank
you representative yeah in that could
could we just clar so I think there was
10 million doll
appropriated in the last budget and then
there was the additional 40 but the 40
was also in the operating budget but it
was set to be amortized it wasn't in the
capital budget I think that's I think
mechanically they they're going to have
to do something to move it to the
capital budget because it's a capital
expenditure you have a conversation I
think that's how it how it worked and I
did I mean just for what it's worth I
did look at the capital budget because I
was wondering what they were doing about
this and it's just more maintenance in
there they don't have right yeah
right yeah it's a
lot um can I just ask Mr chair you
usually do a debt affordability study
for the public works have you already
done that yes we it's ready right now I
was posted on the website but I can
certainly share that with you um yeah
that would be really helpful yes
absolutely thank you you're welcome all
right let's turn to
so it's cheated property is what
um this funds that been as cheated to
the general fund but because we have to
pay um regardless of um if if if the
rightful owner of that property can come
to us and request um and as soon as we
validate that it is the right person we
are able to pay that person so um that's
not typically budgeted so that every
year when we to a general fund
essentially we take some of that money
back and so that's recorded in here so
it's not in the budget that's why you
don't see it in 25 but you see activity
in 24 and again you're not going to see
anything in 26 and 27 but it is
typically about that amount what we see
um um being taken from um back from the
general fund is this the same
as yes yes well
it is yes it's just the how it's um
title here but it is essentially those
funds that Weg to general fund every
year is a portion of that that we pay
every year and that's that's where you
see the activity reflected
there's a big jum between what you sp4
what you're Bud next years yes the
current expense yes that
that so the reason you see a big
difference here is uh we typically
budget sufficient funds in the current
expenses line and that is for um the
actual account is is amounts that we pay
to um audit firms those other firms do
outut ofate audits multi-state Audits
and um we don't pay them until they
report when they finish their audits and
they collect um an x amount of property
that's when we pay them approximately
10% but because we don't know how much
they're going to report and remit to US
every year we normally have um that line
is budgeted um around the you know about
the same same amount every year but but
again for example in 24 we only spend
500,000 um in 25 I'm not I may have the
activity I actually might have the
activity but but again we we have that
is just so we don't um we don't it's not
like we'll spend that if if it's not
it's just it's just reserved it's
budgeted but if it's not um if it's not
spent then it just laps us back into
that that farm that fund so this this
activity of the abandon property um by
law we're able to cover administrative
expenses with before we es Che the funds
to a general fund we take a small
portion of it and we pay ourselves for
this program um so if we don't again if
we don't have to pay those other FS we
just pay less but that's the reason you
see it like it's it's larger than actual
expenses in
24 but it's only we only pay them if
they bring us
property so so you're not
expecting I mean shouldn't we budget
what we actually expecting to the the
only all representative Cal yes thank
you Mr chair so to that point what has
the average been it's was
500,000 16 56,000 last year what has the
average been over say the last 5 to 10
years it really varies is that's the
reason we don't we don't really know how
many audits are going to be completed in
a particular year um so typically is is
is it's not quite that amount but um or
or better said what what has been your
maximum so that yeah I don't really have
that number but I can take a look at
that but again if we don't spend the
money if we don't uh it's not like we're
going to spend that money is is we only
pay them 10% of all the property that
wereit to us which is you know this year
we're um expect to collect about $25
million so it's it's really
a small portion compared to what we
collect and and where does that show up
as Revenue so this is the abandon
property so it's essentially this is
recorded in in an account and is a
actually a liability account so because
this is so this is so you only see a
portion of that activity in this
accounting unit is just what we end up
paying for administerial cost but all of
the other money is essentially the
abandon property account has increased
by that amount um we return from that
account and what we don't return after 3
years we cheated through the general
fund so it's not activity that flows
through this account is is separate in a
liability account the financial
statements show in a liability
account so where can I see the monies
going to the general fund in this um so
that's unrestricted revenue and last
year was cheated I think it was 19
million
um so they have a staff that does
nothing else and then they have that 10
page thing that gets published in the
newspaper at least once a year sometimes
twice and that's page after page of of
names and and money so yes so last year
we cheated 19 million in this year we
anticipate um it's going to increase
like 23 million something like that
all right so so let's get a
um a history plus plus an the budgeted
amount for 26 and 27 okay so again this
is this is this is not General funds
this is all pay with with those
unclaimed property
funds right but you said it becomes
General
funds it will eventually reduce a small
amount of the general fund but it's it
but yes of course I can definitely get
that it doesn't become 19 million of
General fund it will still be 19 million
and
more okay so that's to me that's a big
number not a small number but that was
still that for you it's a small number
she was saying that will still happen
very little actually goes back to its
original correct get keep it all that's
the oh I see correct because because
historically we don't return all of the
unclaimed property that gets reported to
us so what the um of course yeah um we
only we only historically I think right
now we're at like a
20% we of the of the property that we
receive we only return about 24% so
right now we are expected
to yeah because we only get it after the
bank or whoever has been trying to give
it back correct or you know so it's
already you know another level okay
that's correct so on 25 we're expect to
receive we expect that we're going to
cheat about 22 million and 26 23 million
and in 27 is 26 million and all that's
unrestricted Revenue okay not it's not a
bad thing to add to the bottom line well
I'm sure it is already was right way
means know okay okay all right um let's
see I've got lots more questions so I
think we're going to end up asking you
back um any anyone else want to jump in
okay um let's go to Grants which is on
page actually let's go to um keep on
death service page
144 so I noticed you you separate out
the University's Debt Service from all
the other Debt Service uh and school
building Aid why is
that right so the univers The Debt
Service for the University system is
paid with General funds and we that used
to be all together with the with all
General funded debt and I will say I
think it
was
2019 at some point that that was split
and I think it was a request from the
governor's office at the time to have a
separate place for this for for The Debt
Service for un the university system so
since then we we keep it separately but
it's all paid with General funds the
school building Aid that is that service
that is going to end in 2029 and that's
pay with meals and rooms
tax and that's why it needs to be
separate okay now back to the
university is any of this depend on
expected new borrowing for the
University or or not yes it has the so
as existing debt and the assumtion that
we're going to issue about 10 million
each year uh for the University system
and that's the amount included in the
capital budget right now
okay so if we stop doing that would it
start to affect fiscal year
27 correct okay so 26 is kind of fixed
because we're doing it now I understand
okay good um
all right let's go to page
148 um scholarships and grants College
savings commission so there's a a large
increase from 24 to 25 and that's
carried through to 26 and 27 so where is
this money coming
from it you at page 148 right page 148
that is so
this includes activity
of I think you're you're by the way your
M I hit the wrong button sorry um this
accounting unit it it's it's it's an
activity that actually
facilitates um the financial activity of
the New Hampshire excellence and higher
education trust fund so as a trust fund
uh and because I
think my office years ago in order to
facilitate payments to to um colleges
universities they decided to put it in
this in in this accounting unit so we
make payments to schools for um for the
um the administrative expenses of the um
College SS program and also for two
scholarship programs flow through this
um accounting
unit and two already has his eye on this
money he's Gonna Take It from here and
give it to UNH and and substitute for
some of the 100 million we usually give
them I see but why is it what's the
source of the8 the $5 million increase
Fidelity the managing no no no
specifically from 20 why is 25 different
than
24 so um in 24 um even though we collect
about $18 million in in from that plan
um only 13 million was the dispersed in
Scholarships in um in
25 and 26 and 27 we anticipate that we
will disperse uh those funds to to New
Hampshire schools to New Hampshire
students in New Hampshire schools okay
so you're saying in 24 we took 5 million
and used it for some other purpose it's
it stayed in the trust
fund oh it's in the trust fund it has a
balance representative evil but what was
the source of the funds for this it's
not the 529 plans it is
so the 529 plan um there is um an
administrator assessment is charged to
all 529 participants and the money comes
to the state and is recorded in the
trust fund and so not
everything um well I here we're assuming
we're going to spend all the money but
if we don't end up spending all that
money then we only going to transfer
from the trust fund to this activity to
this accounting unit the amount that is
needed to pay those grants um but but we
do collect about 18 million from from
that charge but it's not really like a
grant or a scholarship I mean I used it
to help put my kids through school it's
it was my own money that I was putting
in so it's not like when I get it back
it's a scholarship right so there're two
different things so the the college
students program the one you were um a
participant of right the f29 plan is
separate so for all of the participants
that charged a small amount is is it
depends on the fund but it's about 10
basis points that we um based on the
assets and the management that's how
much we collect that goes into the trust
fund then um the college to service plan
advisory commission is responsible for
overseeing two scholarship programs that
are funded from that fund um those are
called the unique scholarship programs
there are two types one are direct
scholarships to that go to New Hampshire
students and the other one is um is a
program that funds um institution
endowments all of the colleges
universities have been been
participating in in that program and so
a portion uh goes to those endowments um
lately the commission has chosen to send
less money to the endowments program and
to right to the endowments and send more
funds directly to New Hampshire students
so that's part of the reason why it was
in the past we used to disperse more
funds and you will see higher amounts
here but because we're trying to find in
order to maximize the number of Grants
given to New Hampshire students it's
been a little complicated to find
low-income students that meet a
particular criteria that is determined
and so it so the commission is almost
there trying to disperse as much funds
as possible to benefit New Hampshire
students
this is money we get for name image and
likeness right we for the name New
Hampshire we get this money this is16
billion that's managed by Fidelity this
is the little piece we get because all
these people signed up for the New
Hampshire plan right yeah all right
thank you very much Madam Treasurer so I
I we will ask you back um maybe Melissa
you can find some room on the schedule
sometime okay abolutely she has an H
thank you yeah I do have a couple a
couple items yes yeah perfect thank you
Mr chairman thank
you right and we will welcome the state
Commission on Aging thank you Monica
which is
on
a 107
okay page
107 and
okay maybe there small thing we
talk all right
I got the first two here okay and that's
that's
one got that
[Music]
one thank
you
suspension suspension of room
is that rooms of meals or is
that
okay we'll we'll have to read it we
we'll find out okay do they
show so what how many am I
getting do they show there's a lot for
two people here Commission on Aging is
46 it's it's on page 107 and
okay welcome
ladies welcome thank you thank you for
your time today please what's that thank
you for your time today okay introduce
yourself absolutely uh so my name is
Rebecca Sky I'm the executive director
for the New Hampshire State Commission
on Aging and with me is hi I'm Lori do
I'm the um the chair of the state
Commission
on Lori is uh is the director of senior
services at East seals and comes as she
is a governor appointee to the
commission um and takes time out of our
workday to come here today to be uh to
be part of this presentation so the
commission um on Aging was created
during the 2019 legislative session uh
chapter 19p and is administratively
attached to das the commission's charge
is to advise the governor and general
court on policy and planning related to
aging the commission assesses existing
and potential public policies
Effectiveness in providing an an
opportunity for all of us to age and be
and be a thriving part of the fabric of
our communities in which we live the
driving reason that the commission was
uh created was in response to the
demographic shift New Hampshire is
experiencing currently one-third of New
Hampshire's population is over the age
of 55 the 80 plus population is 4.2% of
our state's population the New Hampshire
Department of uh business and economic
Affairs population projection suggests
that by the 20 year 2030 older adults
will outnumber children in our state um
with uh being one-third of our state's
population um over the age of 65 and by
2050 uh close to 12% of our state's
population will be o um 80 years and
older and this is a rapid permanent uh
transformational demographic shift and
this so you're doing too good a job we
we we need a commission on
youth no so what this commission does is
we try to take advantage of the
opportunity of older adults uh this
growing older adult population is not
just a challenge to our state and County
budgets but it is also an opportunity an
economic opportunity for our state and
so um that's what the commission is here
to help our state realize so um moving
on to how the commission is staffed um I
am the one full-time employee of the
commission um additional staff
supporting the commission are two
part-time employees a project director
who provides admin support to the
commission and runs the older adult
volunteer Awards uh program at 20 hours
a week and a Communications and
Community engagement director who works
16 hours a week to disseminate the
commission's findings from its study of
public policy and issues impacting New
Hampshire uh the commission itself has
26 very committed members including
legislators state agency reps there are
eight state agencies that are
represented on the commission and uh 13
Governor appointees some of whom are
listening on online here
today we publish an annual report um
each November that's the thick thing I
gave each of you you um um the executive
summary of this report is actually the
first page of of the budget pack that
that you have before you and it it it is
a should give you a sense of the breadth
and depth of the commission's work um I
gave you the thicker packet because as
legislators you might be interested in
some of the policy recommendations uh
included
inside um so uh page five of the packet
outlines the commission activities the
full commission meets monthly as does
three commission task force and two
Commission subcommittees
one of those subcommittees turns into
weekly meetings uh during the
legislative sessions session as it
responds in real time to bills before
the
legislature um last year we tracked over
60 bills in the state legislature
providing testimony on 23 bills we've
already provided this session um
testimony on 18 bills to
date we also investigate current issues
and respond to concerns raised by
various stakeholders including the
public at large to hear the those
concerns we conduct Community engagement
sessions throughout the state throughout
the year we also publish a monthly
newsletter targeted to older adults in
the state it intended to capture news
you can use sharing valuable information
on programs and services and public
policy its volunteer uh editor is one of
our commission members and it's it's
really a high quality uh uh newsletter
my humble opinion um and this newsletter
does come to your legislative email
inboxes um um so that you can use it
yourself and you can share it with your
constituents so your office you are not
writing this newsletter uh writing
pieces of it but one of the the
volunteer commission members edits this
newsletter it's actually a newsletter
that has existed in the state for a
number of years before the commission
came to existence by volunteer group and
they asked the commission to take it on
uh to bring forward to talk about
programs that are happened in the state
um and how to access those programs um
but also just in general um there's all
sorts of things that impact how we age
um um choices Etc and education helps
there's getting access to information is
very hard
um but our office does we do have a
constant contact account to deonate the
newsletter um our U admin person
controls the the the mailing list um uh
and mails out the hard copies to the few
people who insist on hard copies um um
and our communication ation director
submits uh contributes at least two
articles a month to it
so
um we also Implement an annual Awards
program honoring older adult volunteers
across the state that has been a
tradition in our state uh since
1962 um and we honor those um we uh
together with the governor of the state
we honor those folks in May which is
older uh American SM um and the
executive council chambers um the last
bullet on page five notes that the
commission is overseeing two arpa funded
projects this year and next other
agencies running uh projects of similar
size typically hire additional staff to
oversee those projects the commission
hired no additional uh staff to oversee
this work um and to carry out this big
lift one project is to study
Transportation issues of non-d drivers
in the state you know do we have enough
Transportation Alternatives do we have
the right alternatives are we maximizing
existing public resources to best serve
New Hampshire residents there are over
5050 potential Federal Government
funding streams that come into every
state in the Union to support
Transportation um are we coordinating
that funding to support uh
Transportation Alternatives these are
just some of the questions um the study
will seek to
answer the second project is is uh is to
connect um is to connect with granite
Staters to learn in a in a very
comprehensive way what opportunities and
barriers families face as loved ones age
here in the Granite State this project
will also engage members of the
legislature to get your ideas uh on what
in state government might need to change
to respond to the demographic shift our
state is facing um does the right
infrastructure exist in our communities
to some support people of all economic
stations to age in their communities
just as an aside we all know rich or
poor um getting services and supports
into the home is almost impossible uh
the workforce just isn't there so moving
on um are those resources organized and
financed in the right way is our state
poised to take advantage of the economic
possibilities of what is called the
longevity economy the some economic
activity driven by the contributions and
needs of people aged 50 and older which
is more significant than any other age
cohorts these findings will be the
foundation um the commission will use to
develop a plan we are calling the agw NH
plan a 10-year multi sector plan vision
for modernizing state government in the
face of trans the transformation
demographic shift we're
facing so moving on to to the discussion
of the commission's um on AG budget um
by looking at the spreadsheet I actually
put a spreadsheet in the budget packet
too if that's I don't know if that's
easier to look at than the the stack of
papers you have in your binders
um um and it's actually I think it's
the yeah it is Page um six thank you so
by looking at page six in the package
you can see that we're a very small
agency with very basic operations 85% of
fiscal year 25's budget is for salary
and benefits if it if you look at class
60 benefits you'll see the largest
increase to this budget compared to
previous years health insurance benefits
unfortunately were in inaccurately
determined in the last uh bium and were
not adequate um those benefits of course
are a necessary part of the commission
budget um fiscal year 25 as you can see
had not quite 30
,000 there um and for fiscal year 26 the
ask is for just over
$70,000 regarding uh Personnel expenses
do the do the Temporaries the part-
timers get some benefits no they do not
see so that's just for the one full-time
executive director position it was it
was a pretty big slip that it was not
accurately um calculated last budget
they had to there's a fund that they had
to borrow from to pay for benefits this
year um
regarding Personnel expenses the fiscal
year 26 efficiency budget reflects a
loss of five hours a week of part-time
assistance this really has a very
significant loss in a in a small
office um reviewing the remaining
non-personnel parts of the fiscal year
26 budget in comparison to 25 the
increases except for class 46 the
Consultants line are largely the cost of
keeping lights on and and really are not
controllable those increases were
required by the department of
administrative services
instate and out ofate travel in fact
were reduced to accommodate the
increases in the required areas the
remaining parts of the budget uh display
H um how we decrease budget lines um
wherever possible to increase the uh the
increase to the Consultants line is to
make the commission compliant with
Federal Regulation and the the Americans
with Disabilities Act um our meetings
are public and communication access is a
requirement uh we have members of the
public who attend who are deaf for whom
ASL English and interpreters are needed
and given our audience many of whom use
hearing aids I almost would say was
almost 100% of our room today we had a
commission meeting today um um it cart
reporting would be extremely helpful uh
we do not have this lovely room setup
you have here with wonderful mics um we
when we first convened we did meet here
in the legislative off office building I
would love to get space in here again it
would really help but in the meantime
cart reporting um would be extremely
beneficial um that's whereby spoken word
is written and displayed real time on a
screen uh 7500 is needed for both these
purposes
um um the fiscal year 26 and 27 budgets
are not flat but nearly so even with the
required uh salary increases uh to
achieve this we did put $6,000 of the
communication access Services uh just
mentioned were put into a prioritized
need request um that was not funded in
the governor's budget um
um another part of the of the
commission's prioritized needs budget
that was not funded was to add back the
5 hours of uh per week for the admin
support that is lost in this budget so
um in closing out and that's a loss of
about um 8,800 in fiscal year 26 and um
close to 8,900 in in fiscal year 27 to
add back those those five
hours um so to close out um there was a
request that we talk about uh the
governor's trailer bill on operations um
the commission has mentioned in section
12 of the uh Governor's trailer bill um
our request is and that really that
request did come from the Commission on
Aging and it's simply to lengthen the
term of Governor appointed members of
the commission from two years to three
on a going forward basis commission
members agree that the current terms are
just too short just as soon as somebody
finally gets up to speed on on all the
issues that we're studying where they
really can begin to have significant
impact on and contribute the work um
they find their term is up so it's a
small change that should make a big
difference in the quality of the work
that the commission's able to achieve
and with that I'm I'm happy to answer
any questions um I don't I this was Lori
was fortunately at the last minute able
to attend today so if there's anything
you would like to
add yeah um no I would just say that I
uh I've been in the uh aging field for
um 35 years and um you know since the
start of this commission there had never
been a um a voice uh for many many years
uh for um collectively informing and and
making people aware of of policy changes
and um uh things that are happening on
the ground with with the folks the older
adults in our communities so with the
collaboration of stakeholders that we
have every one of them have uh have a
pulse on the on the heartbeat of what's
Happening uh in in the entire state so
I just have one question Mr represent LE
I'm sorry the presenter are you Rebecca
Sky yes I am Rebecca I just want to make
sure for the notes I didn't catch it
thanks
okay great handout by the way thank
you okay why um let me ask about the
budget
um your uh it cost is going up
significantly from what you actually
spent in 24 do you know why
um so that number did come from U Das
doit yeah uh I can't tell you exactly
why uh I can tell you we do not need any
new
hardware oh did you in 24 only have one
part-time person is uh uh correct
correct gotta yeah and probably the new
part-time person has a computer yes they
do we are we are fully computered up
yeah so that's why because they charge
you per computer that you have uh yeah
uh could be it could be uh uh there's
there's a lot that's going on behind
that window yeah okay they also um they
do so d uh being administratively
attached there's a lot that Das does for
us we use their HR function we use their
business office function and then with
uh and we get support U through their do
which also supports our website as well
yeah and you probably don't pay rent
right oh we do pay rent yeah um that's
in line is it line28 no rents uh no yeah
transfers to property and plant is
rent oh plant and property I see okay
very good okay other questions
all right um great so uh I guess we'll
read all these
reports and um we can take a break until
3:15 Mr chair yes represent I realize
that we don't have the official
hb2 but oh yes did you want to talk
about there's something in hb2 go ahead
you had just mentioned it briefly but if
we can resolve that at this point we
could cross it off it's just the terms
yes just the terms right extending from
two to three is that correct So
currently um members are eligible for
two two up to two twoyear terms um and I
think that the governor's office would
also appreciate not having as soon as
they yes I'm sure making such regular
appointments okay very good all right so
we will adjourn until uh 3:15 so does
that seem okay okay to you are you just
going to wait till hb2 comes yeah we'll
we'll wait on some of the stuff okay I
was just meant the terms
okay okay thank you for your time today
thank you thank you very
much all
right
e
e e
so so when I check yeah so Melissa I'm
not sure where this one is in the bud in
the book because I'm not sure this is
the same thing as the
developmental disabilities
Council page 15 okay bottom of
page okay thank you they're not on the
index that's my problem oh here it
is
okay so are we separately going to see
the whatever this is um
developmental disabilities or is that
maybe division
three okay yes that's definitely three
okay how about the special ed Advocate
that would be two probably that would be
two yeah
okay that is that's us oh it is yeah so
that's a so administratively attached to
das okay so we will have we have
scheduled them to come in as well but
developmental disabilities is three
three developmental yeah okay all right
so anyways back to page
15 so I'm unprepared then because I
couldn't find
[Laughter]
it
okay it
okay all right and so we will
welcome is this Mr seya it is all right
very
good all
right uh come on up here
Governor's
commission um
disability and so it's page 15 16 and
17 oh no more more 15 oh my gosh all
right so go all all the way through
19 and
[Music]
yeah
okay all
right
disil all right so it's page 15 through
19 yeah
let uh well anyways so welcome Mr
say thank
you I am sir please push your
button thank you uh good afternoon Mr
chairman and good afternoon
Representatives um members of this um
committee I am Chuck seya the executive
director of the governor's Commission on
disability and to my left is our
business administrator Miss Stacy dubia
who obviously plays an integral part of
putting together this uh presentation uh
for today again um once again thank you
for this opportunity Mr chair I I would
defer to you um we do have a PowerPoint
presentation um that's in your packet I
can review the PowerPoint if you'd like
it's about 17 pages I can move along or
I can just give a not to minimize it but
a a high level review so I I I defer to
you whichever type of a present I'm
unfamiliar with with this commission so
um why don't you go through it as
quickly as possible sure I absolutely
will okay so we will go U we'll Turn the
Page and we'll go to page two um and the
state uh the page says that the Ada is
key to understand in the gcd so the Ada
is the Americans with Disabilities Act
the Americans with Disabilities Act was
enacted as a federal law in 1990 and it
ensures that discrimination based upon a
disability is outlawed and is abolished
when we think of the governor's
Commission on disability um our driving
statute is the Ada and as well as that
has now um been codified uh in State
Statute um so we can go over to the page
three um we are administratively within
uh the governor's office although we
have our own physical location when
there is a budget submission we are part
of the uh governor's office um the gcd
we refer to it has an executive director
as well as a staff um and we we actually
we work together for the agency and if
we go to page four but the commission is
made up currently of 15 uh Governor
appointed commission members uh the
commission they're all voting members
the commission meets five times a year
and they they are they represent a
cross-section of of disability uh
persons with a disability family members
or parents or guardians of a person with
a disability uh members of the general
public and organizations that actually
provide um Direct Services so if we go
to page five there are also ex official
members are non-voting members that have
a seat on the commission represented by
uh HHS uh Bureau of voke Rehab from New
Hampshire um Department of Ed supervisor
of blind Services Commissioner of Labor
or design Employment Security or design
and a member of the State Board um of
education so if we go to page six within
the statutory framework of RSA 275c
which is the enabling statute of the
governor Commission on disability um
there's a statutory committee known
known as the committee on architectural
barrier-free design um they are
currently made up of eight members and
they are charged with um promulgating
and Publishing what's known as a code
for barrier-free design which is
essentially what has been adopted is
what's known as the 2010 Ada standards
for accessibility um in its purest form
how many accessible parking spaces are
needed um what are the dimensions for a
counter if an individual um has a
disability and and and he or she is
approaching the counter so when we look
at the physical is a grab rail needed is
a ramp needed is a push plate needed and
that's what the abfc um is charged with
and importantly with the
abfc they actually also render what are
called letters of opinion so when the
state of New Hampshire is going to enter
into a third party lease for uh real
estate so for example um we could use
DMV as an example when they open up a
SAT a satellite location um that will
not be owned by the state typically so
they come before the uh committee on
architecture barrier free design and ask
for an opinion as for accessibility they
render that opinion that then becomes
part of the package that goes to the
governor and executive councel for their
approval so that's where the ab fits in
to the gcd but it's only for state owned
or released buildings correct yes not
right you know Joe's Sub Shop or
something well I well as far as the
within the ab committee you're 100%
right however we do get those calls at
the agency about Joe subshop and whether
or not our um on staff accessibility
specialist can assist oh I see and and
the answer is yes or no um regarding I'm
sorry the the whether you assist them we
do assist yes yes we do assist as much
as we can um now is this uh Ada
standards in Incorporated in the State
Building Code or not yes yeah that's a
great question so the building code
review board as you know promulgates the
uh State Building Code and built within
the State Building Code are Ada uh
standards which mimic um the Ada I think
it's and again I think it's called an
ANSI I I don't remember what it stands
for but those are the accessibility
standards that are built right into the
State Building Code so that that's a
very good question and do you go before
that board and uh when they make changes
or something excellent question um per
the statute of the building code review
board it requires that a representative
from the architecture barrier free
design committee sit on the bcrb which
is what we have we have a representative
that sits on that because you bring out
a great point there has to be an
intersection of state government meaning
one hand has to know what the other hand
is doing especially when it comes to
accessibility that that is a great
question um if we turn to page seven uh
that is the organization chart of the
agency um right now there are eight um
positions um two of the eight positions
are part time and one of the positions
is vacant which we followed up um in an
email to you Mr chairman regarding the
um vacant position um just reviewing
them we have a client assistance um
program Advocate who works with uh
individuals who essentially are working
within the voke rehab system with title
one under the Ada of employment the
accessibility specialist um deals with
and works with anything that has to do
with architectural or physical
accessibility many calls come from code
um inspectors architects um we have a
new research and Information Specialist
who handles the vast majority of calls
that come into the gcd generally related
to the Ada the number one call that
comes into the gcd is service animals
and what is a service animal and what is
an emotional support animal um to my
left is our business administrator and
Stacy does an incredible job with the
finances um managing the various grants
we have Works closely with division of
personnel um for employee matters builds
the budget and obviously meets with me
on a regular basis with our statement of
Appropriations and detailed register we
have an administrative secretary that
provide support um for the entire office
um over way over to the right is what is
known as a silk the Statewide
Independent Living Program and its
council is housed at our agency and
we'll go through the budget um that has
to do with Independent Living Services
and the ada8 coordinator is the vacant
position um which I'm sure we'll talk
about um further on um if we can okay
the Ada coordinator is vacant that's the
vacant position and which ones are the
two-part time yeah so Ada coordinator is
part-time as well as the Statewide
Independent Living Council program
assistant is parttime and that's aund
that funding correct me if I'm wrong
Stacy comes from our department of Ed
New Hampshire Department of Ed fully
funds the program assistant salary
part-time salary parttime benefits um
and other the Met is as she supports the
um the
council the Statewide Independent Living
Council okay I know there's a lot there
a lot of lot of acronyms too so so what
would the Ada coordinator do if you had
one yeah that that's a a great question
so again in the interest of time um
prior Administration Governor sununu had
tasked the governor's Commission on
disability to put together what was
known as a Workforce task task force to
examine hiring protocols as it pertained
to the state of New Hampshire for
individuals with a disability um what is
onboarding look like if an individual
with a disability is is is attempting to
become employed um by the state or if we
do have an employee with a disability
and that person may have a question
regarding an accommodation that person
may need um the the basically we
discussed it at the workforce focus
group and one of the findings was that
an ADA coordinator how that the
governance Commission on disability
which would work closely with the
division of personnel would act as a
resource for other state agencies when
they when they're dealing with questions
that either may come from a potential
candidate or from a candidate uh strike
that from an employee that's already
employed because at the end of the day
the the theme is is for an individual
with a disability to have compe
competitive integrated employment and we
thought that this would be uh as a
finding would be a uh basically a Stella
point for the State of New Hampshire so
that's the Ada coordinator thank you
sure um if we go to page eight Mr
chairman and and representatives again
some of the core functions we advise the
Governor State a sister agencies New
Hampshire legislature and the public on
the needs and the rights of interests uh
of citizens with disabilities um we
educate and train Rada um so the gcd the
agency is not an enforc agency um
however we do whatever we can When Calls
come into the office or emails come in
we we're averaging about close to 500
calls um or emails or inquiries that
come up come in every year um regarding
Ada and it truly does run the gamut a
service animal benefits questions
housing questions and where we sit as a
resource where our intent is just not to
give another 800 number or just call
this person we look at a little
differently let's see what we can do to
resolve the matter inhouse um with the
understanding that although we don't
have that enforcement capability if we
can resolve something at the lowest
possible level we believe it would would
suit the the citizens of New Hampshire
Best and thankfully we have a very good
track record of of speaking to
businesses of speaking to employees of
speaking to landlords what can we do to
work this out so that it doesn't have to
um get elevated so that's that's how we
we look at the GC um if we go to page
nine there is a program um pursuant to
RSA
195k that is that is known as the NH
able plan the NH able plan is New
Hampshire's able Savings
Program um our legislation became
effective in 2016 and essentially it
allows an individual with a disability
to save money without jeopardize and
needs-based benefits like Medicaid or
SSI across the country this is not
particular to New Hampshire if an
individual with a disability is
collecting SSI on Medicaid and if they
hit a threshold which is typically
$2,000 they could lose their benefits um
National legislation came about in 2014
States rolled out their own able plans
and we have an able plan I'm in New
Hampshire that is actually
co-administered statutorily by that's
the executive director of the gcd as
well as the state treasurer whom you
just saw about an hour ago moniker and I
work very closely is um in essence we
have um $12.2 million uh in management
uh assets and 1,900 accounts there are
no General funds um so essentially when
the uh legislation was passed in
2016 um it appoint the gcd executive
director as well as state treasur to in
their staff to run the program um and
and I have to tell you it's a high point
for the State of New Hampshire that
these exist Mr chair representative I
well just f following on to what you
said I I have a disabled constituent um
who just couldn't wait for this program
to start and now is a participant and
just can't say enough and the family
loves it and so kudos to you for a great
operation thank you representative it
truly is with with the state treasur
myself it it is an it's an important
part of the equation the prior program
was known as stable and and and the
prior um uh State Treasurer myself and
and I say this we we just hit the road
and we just went across the state
explaining to people the benefits of
this program uh it it truly is a game
changer you can save up to 18,000 a year
without risking any um loss and and if
you're working um that's increased to
just over $32,000 a year it's a
definitely a a a wonderful program Game
Changer well it's a great help to live
independently and yes yeah which is
really important yeah in if I may what
what the stories we hear is that if a
grandma or if a family member wanted to
give a birthday gift to their grandchild
who had a disability well and again this
is not unique to New Hampshire they
didn't want to give the gift because
they were so
concerned about yeah maxing out yeah and
so long as the money is spent on what we
call a qualified disability expense it
mimics College savings so this is the
529a plan College savings is 529 so it's
it's my so is this interest bearing uh
it is yeah so there's different um there
were different portfolios cuz we OB we
have a what's known as a Record Keeper
um who manages the accounts um and
basically you can have a very aggressive
um long-term goal oriented type of
Interest or you can choose a checking
account with a debit account that mimics
um you know the ordinary checking
account that probably gets it's FDIC
insured but hardly gets any interest on
the money so the so the the investor has
the opportunity the individual with a
disability is the owner of the account
do you know what the expenses of the
program is yeah um you know I I if you
don't mind I could get back to you sir
on that I can give you a um it's it's
very competitive I I want to say about
35 a year but but again please don't
quote me on that but I'll definitely get
that info thank you so maybe a quarter
of a percent like and then I think there
were different fees and this is where I
would lean on my colleague uh treasure
mipel there are different fees um within
the investment itself um that they may
choose but I can get that information to
you thank you sure on page 10 again from
a very high level the client assistance
program facilitates discussions between
persons with disabilities and Vocational
Rehabilitation um that is in a different
accounting unit but the cap on budsman
um is 100% federally funded um again a
very important piece of the equation
because every state uh in America has a
client assistance program and the gcd is
the designated recipient of the federal
funds and also we house the UN budsman
of the
program so back in your your picture of
the agency yeah was one of these I think
it was the first one sir the the very
first one the um client assistance let's
see yeah oh the udman the udman which
would be the first yeah okay yep so this
is
okay great
okay um and if we go to page 11 I had
referenced this is the parttime position
the Statewide Independent Living Council
um and the council itself provides
advocacy for Independent Living the
governor's Commission on disability is
under a contract with New Hampshire uh
education department and we can receive
up to 990,000 essentially draw down for
salary benefits um supervisory fees
assessed to me um Grant um Grant
operation and management fees as apply
to the business administrator and any
other items that the uh program
assistant may need um we're actually
will be entering to a um new contract
negotiations with the Department of Ed
because the current contract expires
June 30th if I'm not mistaken yes this
year of this year yes it's typically a
two-year
contract and on page 12 a couple why why
is the Department of Ed involved I don't
understand yeah another great question
so over the years what has been
interpreted and this has been before my
coming on board um the governor's
Commission on
disability um per the interpretation of
this the federal statute the Statewide
Independent Living council's Program
assistant cannot be housed um in the
same um agency that is considered the
designated State entity which is the
Department of Ed so over the year Well
prior to my coming on board the gcd
entered into a contract with the
Department of Ed to house the Statewide
independent programs um
assistant
okay and if we and if I'm going too fast
I apologize on page 12 couple other
programs um that we administer there is
a program known as the T Communications
equipment assistance program um this is
non-general funds and the funds come
from the puc's relay service trust
fund um and statutorily
96,000 a year um is appropriated to the
governance Commission on disability and
every two years um we put an RFP
together and we um we solicit bids from
um a third- party contractor to act to
operate the te as we refer to it as and
what the te does it provides um various
types of communication and equipment to
individuals with a disability so if
you're an individual who is De for hot a
hearing there is equipment there um for
close caption phones um if you are an
individual who is deaf and um you need
um an alert when someone is ringing a
doorbell it alerts them so those are
some of that's some of the equipment um
that that is within the te program the
program is currently operated by Future
Insight which is a provider of Direct
Services um in the uh State of New
Hampshire so are these just given or are
they at a lower cost both applies it
dependent upon great question um it
basically the individual will have to
fill out an application which is driven
by our rules and then it will either the
the the equipment although always stays
the property of the governor's
Commission on disability it's either a
50 50 split or the um the equipment goes
over if they're eligible thank you go
ahead represent do you have more people
applying than you have
funding would you
know I don't think so no so you think
it's adequately I I do yeah so so I I
think and again I'd have to lean on
Stacy the current contract that was
awarded was probably 91 I think close to
91,000 91,000 and I think the V and Drew
down what would you say about 70,000
about 70,000 I so and future Insight is
for the blind it is that is correct you
know someone else who's worked with them
and they've just been fabulous yeah
future Insight again representative if I
may miss the chair um again because they
provide the Direct Services and because
they're so ingrained in the community um
they also have the ability they they'll
do whatever it takes to reach out to the
rest of the other organizations that
represent uh individuals various types
of disabilities we've they've been the
vendor is it six years Stacy do you
remember off hand I think six years six
years they they do a really good job
yeah okay how many applications do you
get per year you know we don't see the
applications I'd have to um future
Insight get them and we do have an
annual report um that Stacy linked I
don't have access but on your page 12 um
is an annual report I I didn't bring the
annual report with me I'm more than
happy to forward that to you as well sir
if you'd like your report
yep
okay um another program oh excuse me on
page 13 is what is known as the national
Federation of the blind news lines for
the blind which essentially is a service
that if you for whatever reason you
cannot access the print media very
similar to like the talking books um
this is a new service um that will
actually um dictate over F various
Publications to an individual um with
the disability in New Ham there's an
appropriation of
31,500 for purposes of the gcd Mr
chairman and representatives we don't
get any money we're a pass through on
that um however we do work very closely
with nfb newsline to ensure that there
were two um Publications um in New
Hampshire SE coast online in the
conquered monitor that individuals can
access and there's also what is referred
to as a homepage that individuals um who
would like to post information on New
Hampshire's um home page we can actually
access that as well and again that's
statutorily
driven so so is the nfb newsline
something that someone can access online
and then just see what or how does that
work yeah they can access it online and
they can also access it I believe um on
their um cell phones and it'll dictate
it to them if they want to read New
Hampshire or if they wanted to read um
Beyond oh cool yeah it's pretty good um
and on page 14 um uh we do have a grant
that comes in from what's known as the
New England Ada Center um right now we
um we're receiving in FY 26 4025 and in
in fy2 we're awarded
6,75 um and the reason being is because
they're on a different type of a grant
cycle they're in a five via Grant um we
anticipate that um should we go under
contract with them it'll be very close
to the 16,000 and we serve as technical
assistant with the other New England um
ad with the other um Ada centers um in
New
England and on page 15 what we have done
at the gcd and what we has been very
very aggressive you know when you look
at this the mission of the gcd it's
really to to act as a as a as a as a
source of resource for individuals with
a disability um as a as a panity
Americans with Disabilities Act we have
a very robust social media campaign
we're very very active on Facebook um as
you know we're a small office uh a lot
of cross-pollination as I say I I have a
great team I shout out to the team um
because as you've heard before Mr
chairman Representatives I'm only
they're doing all the work and and I
sincerely mean that and and I'm here
because of them what they work together
um our social media is robust it's
collaborative we just don't post for the
sake of posting We Meet on a regular on
a weekly basis to figure out what are we
going to post and what is the
information um that we can get out on
our website which has been newly
redesigned by doit we have what's called
an ADA assistance form where a person
can go online fill out a form write
online and submit it or they can
download a PDF and we also have an
architectural access inquiry form which
is critical for for those types of
questions Revol revolving physical
accessibility so Ada is general
information and aif um is uh
architectural but again it's to really
make ourselves accessible you know we're
open 8 to four Monday through Friday we
answer our phones we get back to
individuals because many times when the
calls are coming in it's it's it people
are at a stage where they need
information I won't go over 16 but it
just gives you a highlight of the
various organization statutorily within
the State and outside the state that we
sit on um page 17 um just to give you a
a a look at some of the workings the
accessibility specialist looks at
physical accessibility supports the ab
committee deals with code officials
Architects when it comes to physical
accessibility client assistance program
on budsman deals with employment under
the Ada as well as interacts with
Vocational Rehabilitation and our
research and Information Specialist
handles the vast majority um of the um
Ada uh questions that come in on page 18
gives you an idea of the calls that are
the top calls disability employment
service animals
accessibility we want to resolve things
at the lowest possible level as possible
and and that's what our mission is to to
Really assist individuals um if we can
on a voluntary basis um page 19 I
respectfully submit to you Mr chairman
and and and members we we submitted a
streamline budget um there there is it's
it's lean um it's we would say that I
would look at this budget I've looked at
it many times uh to ensure that we're
ready for today um I I truly
understand what we're being asked to do
as with all agencies and that's our
fiduciary obligation I don't run from
that and you know if you're not going to
sit in the chair to make the decisions
don't take the chair and I sincerely
mean that but but I can I can tell you
we we built a budget as streamline as we
could um and uh I'm I will end there
because I'm assuming you'll have
questions specifically on the budget I
took up a lot of your time um but I hope
you found it uh informative and helpful
yeah thank you very much let me let me
ask on um other funds here
um65 two 218 is that the stuff from pu
and doe
yes yes well no go right ahead Stacy
please yeah the other funds are what
page may I ask what page are 19 19
okay and the reason 24 to 25 is
different is one is budgeted and one is
you still have some vacancy right
so I'm
guessing yeah that's PU and wouldn't
that be Ed to
education yeah right educa it was silk
funds it would come from environment um
education I'm taking Environmental
Services New Hampshire education
department
and
pu and the niata funds New England Ada
this the the 16,000 that I referenced um
so those are the other funds gotcha um
just if if you'd like Mr chairman and
representatives what Stacy did on page
20 of our PowerPoint um she broke down I
don't know if um I find it very helpful
she broke down all the general funds um
for your review
too and and where it's coming from
because when we look at
one4 which is the accounting unit there
are the mixed funds that are in there
that are coming from education that are
coming from um Department of Ed oh and
Page 21 has all those funds too there
they come from the state um cap is the
federal
funds um transfer from other agencies
that's from New Hampshire education
department um and then we have the niata
funds which is any uh New England Ada
and then um this is at the bottom bottom
B page 21 yeah and those are going away
no oh no no we were just we thought it
may be helpful if you saw General funds
versus other funds and where they're
coming from no no but I I'm looking at
page 21 okay there's only the 16,000 is
only in 2024 it's not continued go right
ahead um we we don't know because
they're in
a a fiveyear grant and we don't know how
much we get until um
that that Federal fisal year right and
so we didn't want to put any monies in
because it's
been it's it's been as high as 18 or
20,000 I understand to
16,000 yes representative
Griffin thank you Mr chair uh there's
another group that that we have in our
budget in the state called the uh
development disabilities Council
how do their functions and your
functions compare and what are the
differences yeah thank you for the
question it's it's a great question um
what we refer to as the DDC
developmental disabilities councils from
what I understand their funding just
from a is 100% Federal um funding um
and their mission is to assist
individuals with Developmental and
intellectual um disabilities when we
look at the governance Commission on
disability we're cross disability so
although we will work with individuals
who may have a developmental disability
or an in intellectual disability we
could also work with someone um who is
blind or vision impaired or who is deaf
or um an individual who may have um uh
cerebal paly or muscular distrophy so
we're cross disability mental health
issu or mental health issues with at the
gcd um and with the DDC
um it's my understanding that federal
law mandates that every state have a DDC
a developmental disabilities Council as
well so I I don't know if I've addressed
it or if you have any further questions
sir
okay other
questions no Mr chair yes I just want to
correct the statement I said earlier
those do uh the development disability
Council does fall under division one and
they'll be here Thursday okay and they
are 100% Federal fund okay good so
you're correct all right anybody else no
yes is is the difference in general
funds largely
benefits benefits and um there's a temp
that you're and for the one that's
missing the Ada coordinate yeah salaries
too um because we do have some people
who are going to be yeah step increases
or whatever but basically personel
yeah
yes and I if I may Mr chair what we also
um and I'd like to point out if we look
at class
49 um so that's we this is Page 20 by
the way if you want to look at our page
20 yes I'm
sorry um you see a figure of uh 30,
338 um for transfers to other state
agencies so that includes the rent so
we're we're sub tenants of the division
of personnel dop is located at 54
Regional um and we're sub tenants of
them we we um we rent from them um so we
have to pay them a rent and also we
built in with within that figure is also
what's known as hru the human resource
support unit um which I have to tell you
is a great resource especially if you're
a small agency because they deal with
all the personel matters that we not may
not be accustomed to on a regular basis
time cods and and requests on the FMLA
or um so again that that is a that's an
incredible resource and within there
also is granted it's a small figure the
EAP employee assistance program so
that's when we look at you know the the
actuals for 24 and the appropriation for
25 you know what we did was we we we did
what we had to to to build the hru into
our
budget gotta what what You Know by so
that it became a governance
recommended we didn't have Hrs
previously that's what we're saying all
right thank you you're
right all right I guess that's it yeah
all right thank you very much for coming
oh you're very welcome we uh took a
little extra time I yeah sorry about
that I can be long winded that's it was
interesting no it was very interesting I
think you did a very nice job yes thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you members
of this committee all right so we are
going to be meeting on Wednesday at 10
am I
correct yes not tomorrow well
tomorrow yeah I'm going to be here but
8:30
yeah that's well there's no
regular but we might want to all right
let's turn this
off
e for